I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi there.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你录制终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎，女士们。哈喽！大家好。
Angela, can I interest you in a seminar? Let's say podcasting seminar. Oh, are we going to a seminar? Yeah. What do you think? I put up some flyers. Is it just going to be us and Sam and Cassie? Yes, at lunch.
安吉拉，你想听听研讨会吗？比方说播客研讨会。哦，我们要去参加研讨会吗？是的。你觉得呢？我贴了一些传单。难道只有我们、萨姆和卡茜吗？是的，在午餐时间。
Actually, never mind. But there will be sandwiches. There will be sandwiches. There will. This is season seven, episode 14. It's called The Seminar. It was directed by B.J. Novak and written by Steve Healy. Steve Healy was a new writer for us in season seven.
其实，没关系。不过会有三明治的。会有三明治的。会的。这是第七季第4集。名字叫《研讨会》。由B·J·诺瓦克执导，史蒂夫·希利编剧。史蒂夫·希利是我们第七季的新编剧。
He had previously written for The Late Show with David Letterman and 30 Rock. He was a co-executive producer on Veep. I did a little diving on him, and I found out was reminded, actually, that he wrote this book with Vali Shandrasakran. Remember, he played hot doctor on Diwali? Yes. He wrote a book together called The Ridiculous Race. I remembered this.
他此前曾为《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》和《我为喜剧狂》撰写过剧本。他曾担任《副总统》的执行制片人。我对他进行了一点深入了解，其实是想起来了，他曾与瓦利·尚德拉萨卡兰合著过这本书。还记得吗？他在《排灯节》里演过那个性感的医生？是的。他们合著了一本名为《荒唐比赛》的书。我想起来了。
They decided to race around the world. The two of them? Just the two of them. They started in LA. They each had to go in different directions, and there was one rule, which was that they couldn't use any planes, and they had to see who got back to LA first. And they went around the world? Around the world.
他们决定进行一场环球赛。他们两个？就他们两个。他们从洛杉矶出发。他们必须各自朝不同的方向前进，只有一个规则，那就是不能使用任何飞机，看谁先回到洛杉矶。他们环游了世界？环游了世界。
At one point, the way Steve got out of LA was that he arranged for himself to ride on a container ship from Long Beach to Shanghai. What? Yeah. They wrote all about it in their book. I want to read this book. It's insane, right? I mean, a container ship.
有一次，史蒂夫离开洛杉矶的方式是安排自己乘坐一艘从长滩开往上海的集装箱货轮。什么？是的。他们在书中详细记录了这一切。我想读这本书。太疯狂了吧？我是说，集装箱货轮。
Anything can happen out there. Get out in the wide open ocean. I mean, how do you do that? How do you convince someone to let you ride on a container ship? I don't know. I guess I'll have to read the book. Steve also wrote a book called The Wonder Trail, where he traveled through Central and South America.
那里什么都有可能发生。来到一望无际的大海。我是说，你怎么做到的？你是怎么说服别人让你坐集装箱货轮的？我不知道。我想我得读读这本书。史蒂夫还写过一本书叫《奇迹小径》，记录了他穿梭中南美洲的旅程。
And he also wrote a novel called How I Became a Famous Novelist, which won the 2010 Thurber Prize for American Humor. That's so cool. Yeah, so he's been writing a lot of books since we saw him. But he also wrote this episode. Would you like a summary? Yes. As a ploy to get new clients, Andy hosts a business seminar in the conference room
他还写过一部名为《我如何成为一名著名小说家》的小说，并获得了2010年瑟伯美国幽默奖。太酷了。是的，自从我们见到他以来，他一直在写很多书。但他也写了这一集。你想要个总结吗？好的。为了吸引新客户，安迪在会议室举办了一个商业商务研讨会，
and enlists the help of his fellow employees. Jim mysteriously skips out after recognizing one of the attendees. Michael and Holly start to reconnect by pretending to be a Greek couple. Oscar and Pam help Aaron play Gabe in an online game of Scrabble. Well, Jenna, fantastic summary. I know you have some hot fast facts for us. And after that, I have a little digital clutter. We'll buckle in, everyone.
并争取到了同事们的帮助。吉姆在认出一个与会者后神秘地溜走了。迈克尔和霍利通过假装成一对希腊夫妇开始重新建立联系。奥斯卡和帕姆帮厄兰在在线拼字游戏里对付盖布。好吧，珍娜，非常棒的总结。我知道你有一些劲爆的速成冷知识要带给我们。在那之后，我有一些数字杂物要分享。大家系好安全带吧。
Let's get started. Fast fact number one, this episode aired on January 27th, 2011, and it won its time slot for the night. Again. Woo. Way to go, office. Before this episode aired, they had just announced to the press that Will Ferrell would be joining us for a four episode arc at the end of this season.
我们开始吧。冷知识一，本集于2011年1月27日播出，并赢得了当晚的同时段收视冠军。又一次。呜呼。干得好，办公室。在本集播出之前，他们刚刚向媒体宣布，威尔·法瑞尔将在本季末加入我们，进行为期四集的客串。
And there was a lot of buzz. Do you remember the buzz? We were so excited. Oh, my gosh. I mean, we were like sad excited. We were like, oh, no, Steve, well, Will Ferrell, yes. So they released this news on purpose. They wanted the buzz.
当时有很多舆论反响。你还记得当时的轰动吗？我们太激动了。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我们是那种悲喜交加的激动。我们当时想，哦，不，史蒂夫，不过，威尔·法瑞尔，是的。所以他们是故意发布这个消息的。他们想要这种舆论热度。
It was a bit of a red herring. Oh, intrigue. They were trying to distract from something else. And what was the other thing? I know you're going to tell us. They were trying to distract everyone from the big cameo guest star that kicks off this episode, Ricky Gervais, as David Brent has come to Scranton. David Brent and Michael Scott meet.
这有点像是个烟雾弹。哦，悬念迭起。他们试图转移对其他事情的注意力。那另一件事是什么呢？我知道你会告诉我们的。他们试图转移大家的注意力，不再关注本集开场的重量级客串明星里奇·热维斯，也就是大卫·布伦特来到了斯克兰顿。大卫·布伦特和迈克尔·斯科特见面了。
I mean, for any office fan, this is a huge moment, huge. And that is fast fact number two. We're going to break down this cold open and tell you all about Ricky coming to the office. Kick it off. Well, it all starts at some elevator bays. Yeah. Michael runs into a very nice English fella who's getting off the elevator who says his
我的意思是，对于任何《办公室》粉丝来说，这都是一个巨大的时刻，超级巨大。这就是冷知识二。我们要剖析这段冷开场，并告诉你所有关于里奇来到办公室的故事。开始吧。好吧，这一切都从某个电梯间开始。是的。迈克尔遇到了一位非常nice的英国老兄，他正走出电梯，并说自己
name is David Brent. Michael immediately does a British accent or his attempt to. And then David Brent shares that he also does accents and characters. And then they go back and forth with their various characters that they do. They are delighting one another. Oh my gosh. Kindred Spirits. David then says comedy is a place where the mind goes to tickle itself.
的名字叫大卫·布伦特。迈克尔立刻学起了英国口音，或者说他尝试这么做。接着大卫·布伦特表示他也擅长模仿口音和角色。然后他们用各自模仿的角色你来我往地对话。他们乐在其中。哦，天哪。志同道合。大卫随后说，喜剧是心灵自我挠痒痒的地方。
That's what she said. Michael can't believe it. This is his soulmate. Yes. You thought Holly was his soulmate. Here it is. Yeah. Michael hugs him.
她也这么说。迈克尔简直不敢相信。这就是他的灵魂伴侣。是的。你以为霍利是他的灵魂伴侣。原来是这。是的。迈克尔拥抱了他。
Goodbye. Yes. And then David says, are you guys hiring? He said no. Mm hmm. And then he said, well, think of me if something comes up and he leaves and Michael's like, what a nice guy. I'm sure you can imagine we got a lot of mail about this.
再见。是的。然后大卫说，你们在招人吗？他说没有。嗯哼。然后他说，好吧，如果有空缺的话考虑我一下，然后他就离开了，迈克尔觉得，真是个好人啊。你可以想象，我们收到了很多关于这部分的邮件。
Oh yeah. I'll kick it off. First up is Karen C. from Delaware as well as many others who would like to know where was the cold open supposed to be because it doesn't look like the industrial park where Dunder Mifflin is located. Karen, I feel seen. I wrote in my notes where the heck is this elevator? Well while we were shooting the episode, The Sting, you remember that one where they meet
哦，是的。我来开个头。首先是来自特拉华州的凯伦·C，以及许多其他人，他们想知道这个冷开场本来应该在哪里拍摄，因为它看起来一点也不像邓德米夫林所在的工业园区。凯伦，我感觉自己被看到了。我在笔记里写道：这电梯到底在哪儿？好吧，在我们拍摄《潜伏》那一集的时候，你还记得他们遇到
Danny Cordray? Oh yeah. The teacher face happened to be in town for, I don't know, a celebrity appearance or something and he just volunteered to come in and do a scene for us. He said, I want to do a scene with Steve. Awesome. Yeah. So they were like, well, we're at this location.
丹尼·科德雷的那集吗？哦，是的。蒂娜·费恰好在城里参加什么名人亮相之类的活动，她就主动提出过来为我们拍一场戏。她说，我想和史蒂夫演一场戏。太棒了。是的。所以他们就想，好吧，反正我们在个地方。
Why don't you come on down? So we shot it there at that same place at those same elevators, you know, the one where Michael wonders if the buttons even work. Mm hmm. Randy said he had to create a stealth call sheet. He did not put Ricky's name down. They did not want this cameo to get out. They lied to NBC about it.
你为什么不顺便过来呢？所以我们就在那个地方、在那些电梯旁拍了，你知道的，就是迈克尔琢磨着按钮到底管不管用的那个地方。嗯哼。兰迪说他必须制作一份隐秘的通告单。他没有把里奇的名字写上去。他们不想让这个客串消息泄露出去。他们为此对全国广播公司撒了谎。
They have the habit of doing that. Yes. They didn't want any promos. That's why they did the whole Will Ferrell press release. All of it. But guess what? What? The week before the episode aired, it got out.
他们有这种习惯。是的。他们不希望有任何宣传片。这就是他们发布整个威尔·法瑞尔新闻稿的原因。全都是为了这个。但你猜怎么着？什么？就在剧集播出的前一周，消息还是泄露了。
Hollywood Reporter ran a story that Ricky was going to be on. Paul Lieberstein was even quoted for the episode, but he was very careful. He wouldn't say how or why Ricky was going to be on the show. It did leak a little bit, but we tried. We tried not to leak. We made it all the way to the week before. Next up, we have a fan question from Amanda C in Indiana who says, I just have to know how much the cold open was scripted.
《好莱坞报道》发表了一篇报道，称里奇将出演。保罗·李伯斯坦甚至为这一集接受了采访并被引用了话，但他非常小心。他没有透露里奇将如何或为什么要出演这个节目。虽然确实泄露了一点点，但我们尽力了。我们努力不让它泄露。我们一直撑到了播出的前一周。接下来，我们有来自印第安纳州的粉丝阿曼达·C的一个问题，她说，我必须知道冷开场有多少是按剧本演的。
It almost seems like Ricky is genuinely breaking and reacting to Steve's version of Michael. His laugh just seems so genuine. I want to know everything about their interaction while filming. Well, Amanda, there was a script for this cold open between the two of them. Our writers got together and wrote 11 versions of this scene. In the scripted version, they were on the elevator together like one of them would be on and the other would enter and this would start the conversation. But when they got there on the day, they kind of realized, you know what, these two guys
看起来里奇真的笑场了，并且对史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔做出了真实的反应。他的笑声看起来太真诚了。我想了解他们在拍摄时的互动的一切。好吧，阿曼达，他们两人之间的这段冷开场确实是有剧本的。我们的编剧聚在一起，写了这个场景的11个版本。在剧本版本中，他们一起在电梯里，比如其中一个人先进去，另一个人再进去，然后由此展开对话。但当他们在拍摄当天到达现场时，他们有点意识到，你知道吗，这两个家伙
are really funny. We're just going to let them talk outside this elevator bay. And that's what they did. I reached out to our editor, Dave Rogers, and I was like, Dave, were there any alts for the scene? I mean, come on. And he said, you know, and we put the best stuff in the bloopers. It was mostly Steve cracking Ricky up that day.
真的太搞笑了。我们索性就让他们在这个电梯间外面聊天吧。他们就是这么做的。我联系了我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，我问，戴夫，这个场景有什么备选镜头吗？拜托。他说，你知道的，我们把最好的内容都放进NG花絮里了。那天基本上都是史蒂夫把里奇逗得哈哈大笑。
That's what I remember hearing. Dave went on to say that he wasn't there the day they filmed this, but he really remembers editing the bloopers so clearly because Ricky's laugh is so loud. He said at one point, Ricky even said, I'm not even a real actor. I just love how much fun they were having. I thought we should hear the bloopers. I'm working on an English character. Would you mind?
我记得听到的就是这样。戴夫接着说，他拍摄那天不在现场，但他对剪辑NG花絮印象非常深刻，因为里奇的笑声太响了。他说有一次，里奇甚至说，我甚至都不是个真正的演员。我只是喜欢他们玩得有多开心。我觉得我们应该听听NG花絮。我正在塑造一个英国角色。你介意吗？
It's called Reginald Poofta and. Come on. Come on. Good game. Dave. Sorry, Mike. I forgot me snuttered crane. Pretty good.
它叫雷金纳德·普夫塔，然后……拜托。拜托。好球。戴夫。对不起，迈克。我忘了我的搭讪台词了。挺不错的。
I'm so sorry. Right. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
非常抱歉。对的。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. Right. Okay. This is no good. I'm not even a real actor. Let me out. All right. We have one more fan question for this cold open.
对的。好吧。这不行。我甚至都不是个真正的演员。放我出去。好了。关于这个冷开场，我们还有一个粉丝提问。
It's from Mel W in Calgary, Alberta, Canada. Mel, what you got? When Michael Scott meets David Brent waiting for an elevator, one thing that always seemed off considering the fact that David Brent himself had once been in a documentary in the UK is why didn't he acknowledge or comment on the fact that there was a camera crew standing there filming Michael? It seems like a major opportunity for David to talk about his own documentary or to say something idiotic to the camera like he used to.
来自加拿大艾伯塔省卡尔加里的梅尔·W。梅尔，你有什么问题？当迈克尔·斯科特在等电梯时遇到大卫·布伦特，考虑到大卫·布伦特本人曾在英国的一部纪录片中出镜过，有一点总是让人觉得怪怪的，那就是为什么他没有承认或评论现场正站着一个摄像团队在拍摄迈克尔的事？对于大卫来说，这似乎是一个绝佳的机会，可以谈论他自己的纪录片，或者像过去那样对着镜头说一些愚蠢的话。
Mel, this is so smart. Yeah. I didn't even think of it when I was watching it. But of course, David Brent would be very savvy. Yeah. To the camera crew. Unless we don't know when in time this happened. What do you mean?
梅尔，这太聪明了。是的。我自己在看的时候甚至都没想到这一点。但当然，大卫·布伦特会对摄像团队非常精明。除非我们不知道这件事发生在时间线上的什么时候。什么意思？
What if this scene happened in the canon of the show before David Brent got a camera crew? Maybe this inspired David Brent to be like, will you come film me at my job in Slough? Oh my gosh. My mind is bending right now because you're suggesting that maybe Dunder Mifflin happened before Wernem Hogue happened. Yeah. And that Dunder Mifflin and Michael Scott and his camera crew are what inspired David Brent to want to do the same thing.
如果这个场景发生在剧集正史中大卫·布伦特拥有摄像团队之前呢？也许这启发了大卫·布伦特，让他觉得：你们愿意来我在斯劳的工作室拍我吗？哦，天哪。我的脑子现在有点转不过弯来了，因为你在暗示，也许邓德米夫林发生的时间比沃内姆·霍格公司还要早？是的。而且是邓德米夫林、迈克尔·斯科特以及他的摄像团队启发了大卫·布伦特，让他也想做同样的事情。
Yeah. I feel that. I feel him going back and being like, I met a guy in America. They follow him around. You want a camera? You want a camera around? I mean, come on. Hey, BBC One, I have an idea for you.
是的。我能理解这种感觉。我能感受到他回去后说：我在美国遇到一个人。他们一直跟着他。你们想要个摄像机吗？你们想要个摄像机跟着吗？我是说，拜托。嘿，BBC一台，我有个主意。
Wow. Good one, Ange. You're welcome. You guys, there is no spoon. There is no spoon. We love you, Kiana. We love you. All right.
哇。说得好，安吉。不客气。各位，世上本没有汤匙。世上本没有汤匙。我们爱你，基安娜。我们爱你。好的。
Fast fact number three. Are you ready? I'm ready. It's a deep dive. And it's a deep dive on Scrabble. The game? The game. Because that's what Gavin Aaron are playing.
冷知识三。准备好了吗？我准备好了。这是一个深入探讨。我们要深入探讨拼字游戏。那个游戏？那个游戏。因为那是加文和厄兰在玩的游戏。
Yeah. I love Scrabble. We just played it last weekend as our family game night. Well, every once in a while, I'll Google something that appears in an episode. And if it's interesting, I want to share. So I Googled Time Magazine, Britannia.com, Wikipedia and the New York Times. And here's what they told me. Scrabble was originally invented by an American architect named Alfred Mosher Butts in 1938.
是的。我很喜欢拼字游戏。我们上周末家庭游戏之夜才玩过。好吧，每隔一段时间，我就会谷歌搜索一下在剧中出现过的事物。如果它很有趣，我就想分享。所以我谷歌了《时代》杂志、不列颠百科全书网站、维基百科和《纽约时报》。以下是他们告诉我的。拼字游戏最初是由一位名叫阿尔弗雷德·莫舍·巴茨的美国建筑师于1938年发明的。
And he called it crisscross words, not Scrabble. What else did Mr. Mosher Butts say? After he manufactured a few sets on his own, he was not able to sell it anywhere. No one wanted it. No one wanted crisscross words. Oh, Albert, you were so onto something. People didn't know. In 1948, a man named James Brunot, or Brunote, who was a resident of Newtown, Connecticut,
他把它叫做“交叉字”，而不是“拼字游戏”。莫舍·巴茨先生还说了什么？在他自己制造了几套之后，他到处都卖不出去。没人想要。没人想要交叉字。哦，阿尔伯特，你当时明明很有灵感。人们当时不懂。1948年，一个名叫詹姆斯·布鲁诺（或布鲁诺特）的人，他是康涅狄格州纽敦市的居民，
he bought a crisscross words. He was like, I'm going to buy this game, and he loved it. In fact, he asked if he could buy the rights to manufacture the game in exchange for giving Butts a royalty on every unit sold. So he left most of the game unchanged, but he did do a couple of things. He rearranged the premium squares on the board. He simplified the rules a little bit, and he's the one who renamed the game Scrabble. Yes, it's all in a name.
他买下了交叉字。他当时想：我要买下这个游戏，他非常喜欢它。事实上，他询问是否可以购买该游戏的制造权，条件是给巴茨每售出一套游戏支付版税。所以他基本上保持了游戏原样没动，但他确实做了一些改动。他重新排列了棋盘上的奖励格子。他稍微简化了一下规则，而且正是他把这个游戏重新命名为拼字游戏。是的，名字决定一切。
Did you know that Scrabble is a real word? No. It means to scratch frenetically. No. Which is odd that you named this game about having to scratch a lot. Scrabble. Scrabble. Yeah, I was up all last night scrabbling.
你知道拼字游戏（Scrabble）本身是个真正的英文单词吗？不知道。它的意思是疯狂地抓挠。不对。真奇怪，你居然给这个必须大量抓挠的游戏起名叫这个。拼字游戏。拼字游戏。是的，我昨晚一直在那儿抓挠来着。
Means you were scratching yourself. So interesting. I need to scrabble. I have poison ivy. I need to scrabble. I don't get it. I don't get it. Scrabble meant when things were jumbled.
意思是你在挠自己。太有趣了。我得去抓挠一下。我得了毒常春藤。我得去抓挠一下。我不懂。我不懂。Scrabble以前是指事情乱成一团的时候。
Right? Yeah. I don't know. All right. So Brunat and his family converted a former schoolhouse into their production facility, and they started making a whole bunch of these games. Guess what? What?
对吧？是的。我不知道。好吧。所以布鲁诺和他的家人把一所旧学校改造成了他们的生产工厂，他们开始大量制造这种游戏。你猜怎么着？什么？
No one wanted them. Oh no. Did he go bankrupt? No. Because in 1952, Jack Strauss, who was the president of Macy's, played the game on vacation. They had given some out to like hotels and stuff, I guess. Game changer. Yeah.
没人想要。哦，不。他破产了吗？没有。因为在1952年，梅西百货的总裁杰克·施特劳斯在度假时玩了这个游戏。我猜他们当时把一些游戏送给了酒店之类的地方。战局逆转。是的。
He loved it. He couldn't believe that no one was selling this game. He said, I'm going to sell it at Macy's. Everyone has to have one. Guess what? Within a year, it had gone, I guess. Number one game. Viral.
他太喜欢了。他简直不敢相信居然没有人售卖这款游戏。他说：我要在梅西百货卖它。每个人都得拥有一套。你猜怎么着？不到一年时间，它就火了，我猜。成了排名第一的游戏。病毒式传播。
Yeah. Yeah. Back in Yieldy version of Viral. Yes. Since then, it has been inducted into the National Toy Hall of Fame, and the game is sold in 121 countries. It's available in more than 30 languages. The original inventor, Mr. Butts, said that he earned about three cents per game in royalties.
是的。是的。属于那个年代的病毒式传播版本。从那以后，它被纳入了全美玩具名人堂，该游戏在121个国家销售。它有30多种语言版本。最初的发明者巴茨先生说，他在版税方面每款游戏大约能赚三分钱。
Here's what he said. One third went to taxes, one third went to charity, and the last third enabled him to have an enjoyable life. Hey. He also said that his wife was the best player of the game. She once scored 234 points for the word Quixotic. Wow. Q-U-I-X-O-T-I-C.
他是这么说的：三分之一用于纳税，三分之一用于慈善，最后的三分之一让他能够过上愉快的生活。嘿。他还说他的妻子是这个游戏玩得最好的人。她曾凭借“Quixotic”（堂吉诃德式的）这个词得了234分。哇。Q-U-I-X-O-T-I-C。
Which means, don't know. I want to know what it means. I'll look it up. Googling music, please. Okay. Ready? All right. Quixotic means, exceedingly idealistic, unrealistic, and impractical.
意思是，我不知道。我想知道它是什么意思。我查一下。请播放谷歌搜索音乐。好的。准备好了吗？好的。“Quixotic”的意思是：极其理想主义的、不切实际的且不切合实际的。
Can you use it in a sentence, please? Okay. One might say, creating a new board game is a Quixotic project. Way to bring it full circle, Fisher. That's all I got. Well, I have a Kinsey tidbit, and I have a digital clutter moment for you. Wow. Kinsey tidbit is, the alt name for this episode was called The Closer, and not The Seminar.
请用它造个句好吗？好的。有人可能会说，创造一款新的桌游是一个堂吉诃德式的项目。真会首尾呼应，费舍。我只有这些了。好吧，我有一个金斯利花絮，我还有一个数字杂物时刻要分享给你们。哇。金斯利花絮是，这一集的备选剧名叫《终结者》，而不是《研讨会》。
Okay. When you go back to shooting drafts, you'll see it being called The Closer. I don't know. I always find that interesting. I do as well. And before we go to break, I just wanted to tell you guys that as I was reading the shooting draft for this episode, I noticed the shooting draft was dated October 21st, 2010. We shot this before we went on our holiday break.
好的。当你回顾拍摄剧本时，你会看到它被称为《终结者》。我不知道。我总是觉得这很有趣。我也这么觉得。在我们休息之前，我只是想告诉大家，当我阅读这一集的拍摄剧本时，我注意到拍摄剧本的日期是2010年10月21日。我们是在放假前拍摄这一集的。
Yeah. What happened? What happened? So I was like, what were we doing? That week in October, I was curious. Okay. Here's what my digital clutter revealed. You and I were in the press that week.
是的。发生什么了？发生什么了？所以我就想：我们在干什么呢？10月份的那周，我很是好奇。好的。我的数字杂物揭晓了这一点。那一周你和我都上了报纸。
What? Why, Angela? I was nominated for an award, and you were my plus one. What was the award and where did we go? Here is what the press statement said. The sixth annual La Femme Film Festival Awards will be honoring Angela Bassett with the Pioneer Award, Virginia Madsen with the Visionary Award, Angela Kinsey with the New Establishment Award, Loretta Devine with the Thespian Award, and Maggie Wheeler with the Comedic Actress
什么？为什么，安吉拉？我获得了一个奖项的提名，而你是我的女伴。那是什么奖？我们去了哪里？以下是新闻稿的内容：第六届拉法姆电影节颁奖典礼将在该节日的颁奖典礼上，向安吉拉·巴塞特颁发先锋奖，向弗吉尼亚·马德森颁发远见奖，向安吉拉·金斯利颁发新势力奖，向洛雷塔·迪维恩颁发戏剧演员奖，向玛吉·惠勒颁发喜剧女演员
and Television Award at the festival's award ceremony, October 17th, 2010. I found a video from the red carpet. No. Yes. But I'm really bummed because I couldn't find any pictures of us, and I know there are some out there. I looked everywhere. I found an email exchange between you and I, and we were debating about my dress, and
和电视奖，时间是2010年10月17日。我找到了红毯的视频。没有。是的。但我真的很沮丧，因为我找不到我们的照片，但我知道网上肯定有。我到处找。我找到了你和我的电子邮件往来，我们在讨论我的礼服，并且
we decided on this sort of deep purple strapless number with an updo. Okay. I love how we would always consult one another on these choices, as if either of us are an expert in fashion or style. I am telling you. Why did we not get other opinions? We are the worst people to ask. I know.
我们决定选这件深紫色无肩带款式并搭配盘发。好吧。我喜欢我们总是就这些选择互相咨询的样子，就好像我们之中谁是时尚或风格专家一样。我跟你说。为什么我们不征求别人的意见呢？我们是最不该咨询的人。我知道。
You and I are like right now in sweatpants and baggy hoodies. Like ridiculous. We are no fashion plates, and it's a real struggle for us, but yet you helped me craft many a red carpet look. Same. All right. Here it is. And who are we talking to?
你和我现在都穿着运动裤和宽大的连帽衫。简直荒谬。我们可不是时尚弄潮儿，这对我们来说真的是个大难题，但你还是帮我打造了许多红毯造型。我也是。好吧。就是这个。我们在跟谁说话呢？
Hi. I'm Angela Kinsey from NBC's The Office, and you've got to be excited to be here tonight. It didn't rain. I know. And you've got quite a few people turning out. Tell me about the LaFemme Film Festival. Is this your first time? This is my first time, and I'm being honored with the new establishment award.
嗨。我是来自NBC《办公室》的安吉拉·金斯利，你今晚来到这里一定很兴奋吧。没下雨。我知道。而且来了这么多人。跟我聊聊拉法姆电影节吧。这是你第一次来吗？这是我第一次来，而且我凭借新势力奖受到了表彰。
I'm really excited about it. I love that this festival brings attention to women in the industry, whether they're filmmakers or they're in front of the camera or behind the camera. And on our show, we have a lot of women in pivotal positions. We have camera operator, we have writers, producers, directors, our first and second ADR women. So I was really passionate about being a part of this. Angela.
我真的对此感到很兴奋。我喜欢这个电影节将人们的注意力吸引到行业内的女性身上，无论她们是电影制片人、台前还是幕后。在我们的节目中，我们在关键岗位上有许多女性。我们有摄像师、编剧、制片人、导演、我们的第一和第二ADR女性工作人员。所以我对能参与其中充满热情。安吉拉。
I know. How about that? The tiny feminist in me is so proud of you for that soundbite. Way to raise up the ladies on our show. Yeah. And my award is really beautiful. I still have it. It's like on my shelf.
我知道。怎么样？我内心那个小小的女权主义者为你这段发言感到无比骄傲。真为我们节目中的女性长脸。是的。而且我的奖杯真的很漂亮。我至今还留着。它就像放在我的架子上。
It's like this big crystal-looking award. So that is what we were doing. Wow. With that, let's go to break because when we get back, you guys, someone here at Office Ladies got their very own microphone. Yeah, I can't wait. We are back and Sam pointed out something, Sam. I can't believe we didn't think of this.
它看起来像个大水晶奖杯。所以，这就是我们当时在做的事情。哇。带着这个，我们去休息一下吧，因为等我们回来时，各位，办公室女郎这里有人拥有了她自己的麦克风。是的，我等不及了。我们回来了，萨姆指出了一个问题，萨姆。我真不敢相信我们没想到这一点。
Sam, you said it's been a hundred and what? It's 146 episodes. I was editing the last episode and every time you talk to me and Cassie, it's me clearly on the mic and then Cassie very faintly yelling. So Cassie, you have a mic now. Yay, Cassie! Say hi to everybody. Hello, everyone.
萨姆，你刚才说已经有多少期了？是146期了。我在剪辑上一集时，每次你跟我说话还有卡茜说话时，都能清楚地听到我的麦克风声音，然后卡茜的声音就非常微弱。所以卡茜，你现在有麦克风了。耶，卡茜！跟大家打个招呼吧。大家好。
Yay! Listen to that. Sorry, it took me 146 episodes to occur to me that this studio is full of microphones. We could totally put one where you sit. Thank you. Thank you, Sam. Well, how's this episode start, Angela? It's going to start with Andy coming in and Aaron very excitedly telling him that his
耶！听听那个。抱歉，我花了146集才突然意识到这个演播室里到处都是麦克风。我们完全可以在你坐的地方放一个。谢谢。谢谢你，萨姆。好吧，这一集是怎么开头的，安吉拉？开头是安迪走进来，厄兰非常兴奋地告诉他，他的
first student has arrived. Yes. Andy has a talking head where he explains that he attended a seminar last year called the Ten Secrets of Real Estate, which ended up being a scam to get him to buy a timeshare in Idaho. But what he realized is that he could throw his own scam seminar to get clients. Yeah. I was curious what the Ten Secrets of Real Estate were.
第一个学生到了。是的。安迪有一个对着镜头的独白，他在其中解释说，他去年参加了一个名为《房地产的十个秘密》的研讨会，结果那是个骗局，目的是骗他在爱达荷州买分时度假屋。但他意识到，他可以自己举办一个骗局研讨会来吸引客户。是的。我很好奇房地产的十个秘密是什么。
Oh, so I had to find out. According to the internet, this is what Andy would have heard. Number one, know your market. Number two, be responsive. Number three, listen to your clients. Number four, manage their expectations. Number five, list like a pro. Number six, build a contact list.
哦，所以我不得不去查一下。根据互联网的说法，这就是安迪当时听到的内容。第一，了解你的市场。第二，保持响应。第三，倾听客户的需求。第四，管理他们的期望。第五，像专业人士一样挂牌。第六，建立联系人列表。
Number seven, never... Number six is build a contact list? Yes, it's a little late. I mean, I don't want to tell the real estate people their business, but I feel like you might want to leave with that. I might want to bump that up. Number seven, never stop marketing. Okay.
第七，绝不……第六是建立联系人列表？是的，有点晚了。我是说，我不想对房地产从业人员指手画脚，但我觉得你可能想把这个排在前面。我可能会想把它提前。第七，永远不要停止营销。好的。
Number eight, negotiate everything. Number nine, carve out a niche. Number 10, ask for reviews. These are some of the secrets to being a top-notch real estate agent. I have to bring up my favorite Instagram account that lists houses called Zillow Gone Wild on Instagram. Come on, guys, it's so good. Have you seen this Jenna, Zillow Gone Wild?
第八，一切皆可协商。第九，开辟一个细分市场。第十，索要评价。这些是成为顶级房地产经纪人的部分秘诀。我必须提一下我最喜欢的列出各种房产的Instagram账号，叫Instagram上的“Zillow狂野大赏”。拜托，各位，这个账号太棒了。你见过这个吗，珍娜，“Zillow狂野大赏”？
No. Okay. It's an Instagram account of houses that are for sale. Okay. And a lot of them look really normal from the outside, but then when you do the carousel of pictures, there's always something wacky. There's like a basement that looks like a dungeon, or there was one, the whole house looked like Tron, the movie.
没有。好吧。这是一个展示待售房屋的Instagram账号。而且它们很多从外表看起来非常正常，但当你翻看图片轮播时，总会有一些古怪的东西。比如有一个地下室看起来像个地牢，或者还有一栋，整栋房子看起来就像电影《创：战纪》。
Oh my gosh. It's like, you know, the website Zillow, but if Zillow Gone Wild, it's gone wild. Zillow Gone Wild. You have to check it out. More students are going to arrive, including Mykonos. Yes. Mykonos, he is a Greek man. Oh wait, it's Michael Scott pretending to be a Greek man.
哦，天哪。就像是，你知道的，那个房地产网站Zillow，如果Zillow失控了，它就变得狂野了。Zillow狂野大赏。你一定要去看看。会有更多的学生到达，包括米科诺斯。是的。米科诺斯，他是一个希腊男人。哦等等，那是假装成希腊男人的迈克尔·斯科特。
But Aaron's not sure. Michael gives a talking head where he explains he's the plant. Every great seminar has one. And I had a little observation here, Angela. I think that Mykonos bears a strong resemblance to Michael Scott season one with the hair slicked back. Oh, and the v-neck. Yeah.
但厄兰不太确定。迈克尔有一段对着镜头的独白，解释说他是托儿。每个伟大的研讨会都有一个。我在这里有一个小小的观察，安吉拉。我觉得米科诺斯梳着大背头的样子，跟第一季的迈克尔·斯科特有着惊人的相似。哦，还有V领。是的。
I was like, oh my gosh, it's season one all over again. I don't know about you, but I feel like I heard a little bit of grue in Mykonos. Tiny bit of grue. Tiny bit of grue from Minions. I'm with you. Andy has recruited a bunch of people to help with his seminar. One of them is Jim Halpert. But Jim notices someone come in to the office and he has a big reaction and he bales.
我当时想：哦，天哪，这简直就是第一季重现。我不知道你们怎么想，但我觉得我在米科诺斯身上听到了一点格鲁的声音。一点点格鲁。《小黄人》里格鲁的一点点声音。我和你想的一样。安吉拉招募了一群人来帮忙办研讨会。其中一人就是吉姆·哈尔珀特。但吉姆注意到有人走进了办公室，他反应极大并临阵脱逃了。
He says, I'm not going to be your intro guy anymore, Andy. Yeah. Tuna Turner, baling. Andy is devastated. How could Jim bill on him? By the way, the flyer that Andy made, he made official flyers. He put them out, I guess, around the city. I looked at it because I wanted to see who had what role in the seminar.
他说，安吉，我不再当你的开场引言人了。是的。金枪鱼小哥，临阵脱逃。安吉崩溃了。吉姆怎么能抛弃他呢？顺便说一句，安迪制作的那张传单，他制作了官方传单。我猜他在全城到处散发。我看过它，因为我想看看谁在研讨会里担任什么角色。
Here's what it said. Dunder Mifflin and Saber present a free seminar, How to Grow Your Small Business, hosted by Andy Bernard, introduction by Jim Halpert. Jim kicked the whole thing off. Yeah. Small business expert Phyllis Smith and special guest speaker Dwight Schrute. The small business experts. And then there was a little asterisk and it said, improve sales, increase customer retention,
上面是这么写的：邓德米夫林与赛博呈献免费研讨会：如何发展你的小型企业，由安吉拉·伯纳德主持，吉姆·哈尔珀特引言。吉姆为整个活动做了开场。是的。小型企业专家菲莉丝·史密斯和特邀演讲嘉宾德怀特·舒鲁特。小型企业专家。然后还有一个小星号，上面写着：提升销售、增加客户留存率、
harness the power of the internet, search engine revolution to take your small business global. Use local radio to reach new customers. Wow. That's everything on the flyer. They're going to cover so much in this seminar. They're going to take you global. This flyer, of course, was made by Henry Sane.
利用互联网力量、利用搜索引擎革命让你的小型企业走向全球。利用本地广播接触新客户。哇。传单上的内容全在这了。他们要在这次研讨会上涵盖这么多内容。他们要带你走向全球。这张传单当然是由亨利·森制作的。
Andy has a talking head where he says this cannot go badly. He's a terrible salesman. He hasn't been making sales. He's counting on this. Right. I went to the candy bag alts for this talking head. No surprise. The character Andy has the most candy bag alts for this episode.
安吉有一段面对镜头的独白，说这不可能变得糟糕。他是个糟糕的销售员。他一直没谈成什么业务。他全指望这个了。对的。我找到了这段独白的糖果袋备选台词。毫无意外。安迪这个角色在这一集里拥有最多的糖果袋备选台词。
Of course. Of course. Here were two that were kind of funny. One, we reveal a whole new part of Andy's past. I love it when we learn a little something now. Andy says, losing Jim is a big blow. If I don't sign any new clients today, my future at Sabre is uncertain. And then what do I do?
当然。当然。有两条还挺搞笑的。第一条，我们揭示了安迪过去的全新一面。我喜欢我们现在能了解一点新背景。安吉说：失去吉姆是一个巨大的打击。如果我今天签不到任何新客户，我在赛博公司的未来就充满变数。然后我该怎么办？
I majored in math with a minor in physics. Not exactly skills the paper sales industry is looking for. A minor in physics? He majored in math. All I hear is that he could tell us all about the clacky balls. Math and physics. Right there. Right there.
我主修数学，辅修物理。这可不是纸张销售行业正在寻找的技能。辅修物理？他主修数学。我只听到他能给我们讲讲那些碰碰球了。数学和物理。就在那儿。就在那儿。
His other candy bag alt, he throws a little shade at Pam. What? Andy says, I liked when Pam was the worst salesman in the office. And I was just second worst. Second worst here is still fifth best, which sounds really good on paper. Fifth best does sound good. Well, Jim is going to cut out. He quickly tells Pam, just tell me when the seminar is over, and he rushes out the door.
他的另一个糖果袋备选台词是，他暗讽了帕姆。什么？安吉说：我喜欢帕姆曾经是办公室里最差的销售员的时候。而我当时只是倒数第二差。这里倒数第二差依然是倒数第五好，纸面上听起来真的很不错。倒数第五听起来确实不错。好吧，吉姆要溜了。他飞快地告诉帕姆：等研讨会结束了告诉我一声，然后他就冲出门去。
Pam is confused. Mm-hmm. Meanwhile, Dwight, Phyllis, and Stanley have gone into the conference room where some of the students have assembled, and they're kind of learning that maybe they are worms instead of whales. Yes. Dwight is asking them about their businesses. There was a line in the shooting draft by the older woman in the purple hat.
帕姆一头雾水。嗯哼。与此同时，德怀特、菲莉丝和斯坦利走进了会议室，一些学生已经聚在那里，他们开始意识到也许他们不是大客户，而只是小虾米。是的。德怀特正在向他们询问他们的业务情况。拍摄剧本中紫帽老太太有一句台词。
Mm-hmm. It was so funny when they asked her what her business was. This is what she said. I don't know exactly, but I know the name. Postabilities. Doesn't that just sound like something? It made me laugh. Angela, I feel like that's something you would say.
嗯哼。当他们问她的业务是什么时，太搞笑了。她是这么说的：我不太确定，但我知道这个名字。邮品（Postabilities）。这听起来不就像那么回事吗？这把我逗笑了。安吉拉，我觉得这是你会说的话。
Postabilities. I have an idea. I'm not sure where it's going yet. There's a lot of pasta involved. Well, I've got a few guest star alerts here. Mindshaft guy was played by Charles C. Stephenson Jr. He's had recurring roles on Will and Grace and Gimler Girls. And the guy I'm calling two cents credit card guy, remember, he's going to make two
邮品。我有个主意。我还不确定它最终会通往何方。这其中涉及大量意面。好吧，我这里有几个客串明星快讯。矿井洞穴男是由查尔斯·C·斯蒂芬森二世饰演的。他曾在《威尔和格蕾丝》和《吉尔莫女孩》中饰演常驻角色。而那个我称之为两分钱信用卡男的家伙，记住，他将赚到两
cents. Yeah. Two cents. I loved it. That was Christopher Nichols-Smith. Chris attended the NYU Tisch School of the Arts and trained at the Atlantic Theater Company. He is the founder, head writer, and principal performer of the sketch comedy troupe Harvard Sailing Team.
分钱。是的。两分钱。我太喜欢了。那是克里斯托弗·尼科尔斯-史密斯。克里斯就读于纽约大学蒂施艺术学院，并在大西洋剧院公司接受过培训。他是素描喜剧剧团“哈佛帆船队”的创始人、首席编剧和主要表演者。
He has appeared on The Mindy Project, How I Met Your Mother, The Newsroom, and Friends from College, and we got a fan catch about Chris from Kanako in Australia. Who said? This is a fast fact. Chris Smith happens to be the co-host of another fun podcast that I listened to, The Alarmist Podcast. It's a podcast about different events in history and who's to blame. I would love this podcast.
他曾出演过《明迪烦事多》、《老爸老妈浪漫史》、《新闻编辑室》和《大学同学》，我们收到了来自澳大利亚的卡纳科关于克里斯的粉丝抓包。谁说的？这是一个冷知识。克里斯·史密斯恰好是我收听的另一个有趣播客《危言耸听播客》的共同主持人。这是一个关于历史上的不同事件以及谁该承担责任的播客。我会喜欢这个播客的。
Okay. Ever since I read this fan catch, I have been listening to The Alarmist podcast. Is it so good? I am obsessed. No way. It's hosted by Rebecca Delgado-Smith, and they take a major event in history. For example, like the Battle of Little Big Horn. Okay.
好的。自从我读到这个粉丝抓包后，我一直在听《危言耸听播客》。是不是超棒？我着迷了。真的假的。它由丽贝卡·德尔加多-史密斯主持，他们会选取历史上的一个重大事件。比如，小大角战役。好的。
First, they give you background history, which is awesome, because I love learning stuff. Me too. Then, they go one by one about who they can blame for this incident in history, and they debate it, and they're so smart, you know, I've always regretted that I didn't pay attention more in college. You know? Don't let your parents hear that. Well, sorry, mom and dad.
首先，他们会给你背景历史，这太棒了，因为我喜欢学习知识。我也是。然后，他们会逐一分析谁该为这起历史事件负责，并展开辩论，他们太聪明了，你知道的，我一直很后悔自己在大学里没有多注意听讲。你知道吗？别让你爸妈听到这个。好吧，对不起，爸爸妈妈。
It was four years where all I was supposed to do was go and just learn. Don't you wish you had time to learn stuff today? I do. I remember I had an English class, and there was an older woman in the class. She was like, quote, unquote, a non-traditional student, like going back to get her degree, and she had the happiest look on her face every day for class, taking notes, taking notes, and I would think of my brain like, oh, look at that little old lady. She's so happy.
那是四年的时间里，我唯一应该做的事情就是去好好学习。你难道不希望自己今天也有时间学习新东西吗？我确实希望。我记得我上过一节英语课，班里有一个老太太。她就像是，引号里的“非传统学生”，就像是回去拿学位一样，她每天上课时脸上都带着最快乐的表情，做笔记，做笔记，我当时脑子里就会想：哦，看那个老太太。她太高兴了。
I mean, that old lady could be me. That would be me. I would be so excited now. That's how I feel when I listen to the alarmist. I feel like I'm listening to a room full of just smart people saying smart things, educating me on history. I love it. Well, I can't wait to listen.
我是说，那个老太太可能就是我。那就会是我。我现在会感到非常兴奋。这就是我听《危言耸听》时的感受。我觉得我是在听一屋子聪明人说聪明的话，向我普及历史知识。我太喜欢了。好吧，我已经迫不及待要听了。
Shout out to the alarmist, Chris Smith. He is their fact checker. He breaks in from time to time. I actually reached out to him on DMs, and I asked him if he had any memories from being on the show. What'd he say? He said he remembered Craig Robinson telling him to knock him dead before they started. He said that filled him with the confidence of 10 men.
向《危言耸听》致敬，克里斯·史密斯。他是他们的事实核查员。他时不时会插话。我其实在私信里联系过他，问他是否有在节目中演出的任何记忆。他怎么说？他说他记得克雷格·罗宾逊在开拍前对他说“大干一场”。他说这让他充满了十个男人的自信。
And then he also said, and I did not remember this, Angela. We shot these scenes on Halloween day, and that one of the crew members was dressed up as Dwight. It was Ed. It was. It was our camera assistant, Ed Nielsen, the third. He said, I think they were a member of the camera department, but this person totally embodied the character and gave an amazing performance all day.
然后他还说，而我完全不记得了，安吉拉。我们是在万圣节那天拍摄这些场景的，其中一个剧组人员打扮成了德怀特。是埃德。是的。那是我们的摄像助理埃德·尼尔森三世。他说，我想他们是摄像部门的成员，但这个人完全融入了这个角色，并且整天都有着令人惊叹的表演。
We have a picture of Ed standing next to Rain within both dressed as Dwight. This was the year that the entire crew dressed as our characters from the office, and we put a bunch of these pictures in the Office BFFs. Yes. Thank you, Chris. Yes. Thank you. I loved your two cents, Guy.
我们有一张埃德站在雷恩旁边、两人都打扮成德怀特样子的照片。那年整个剧组都打扮成我们办公室里的角色，我们把一堆这样的照片放进了《办公室好闺蜜》里。是的。谢谢你，克里斯。是的。谢谢你。我喜欢你的两分钱老兄。
It made me laugh so hard. Yeah. That delivery was perfect. Like, even the way he made eye contact was just spot on for who I think that guy is. Well, now we're going to go to the break room, and Dwight, Stanley, and Phyllis are going to tell Andy they're backing out of his seminar. Bailing in the break room. Yeah.
把我逗得哈哈大笑。是的。那个台词交付简直完美。甚至他进行眼神交流的方式都完全符合我心目中那个家伙的形象。好吧，现在我们要去休息室了，德怀特、斯坦利和菲莉丝要告诉安吉拉他们要退出他的研讨会。在休息室里临阵脱逃。是的。
So uncool. There was a deleted Stanley talking head where he's basically like, cells is not that hard. Here's my technique. I wanted you to hear Stanley's technique. Oh, please. Sales is not hard. Here's what I do.
太不够意思了。有一个被删减的斯坦利单人独白，他基本上是说：销售没那么难。这是我的技巧。我想让你听听斯坦利的技巧。哦，请吧。销售不难。我是这么做的。
I make my pitch, then I stare. Want me to stop? Buy something. And he gives the most intense stare. I would buy something. I'd be like, oh, my God. Wow. That's a sales technique.
我抛出推销词，然后盯着对方。想让我停下来？买点东西。然后他给出最强烈的凝视。我会买点东西的。我会想：哦，天哪。哇。这就是销售技巧。
Mm-hmm. Go Stanley. Stare him down. In our next scene, I have a background catch from Brittany Wyand to Mecula, California. I live for a background catch. What is it? You're going to like it. What?
嗯哼。加油，斯坦利。死死盯住他。在下一个场景中，我有一个来自加利福尼亚州特曼库拉的布列塔尼·怀恩的背景抓包。我最喜欢背景抓包了。是什么？你会喜欢的。什么？
We're over by Holly's desk. Michael has come over. He wants her to be part of a Greek couple with him. Yeah, but she's still bummed about her breakup with AJ. Well, guess what? Sitting there on her desk at four minutes and 35 seconds. The picture of her and AJ in the frame. No.
我们在霍利的办公桌旁边。迈克尔过来了。他想让她和自己扮演一对希腊夫妇。是的，但她仍然对和AJ的分手感到沮丧。好吧，你猜怎么着？在4分35秒时，正摆在她的桌子上。相框里她和AJ的照片。没有。
Oh. A goldfish. She has an entire goldfish bowl on her desk. And it is placed in a really weird way. Like I feel like one elbow bump and that goldfish is on the floor. It's very bizarre. Oh, yes. The goldfish.
哦。金鱼。她的办公桌上放着整整一个金鱼缸。而且它的摆放方式真的很诡异。我觉得只要胳膊肘碰一下，那条金鱼就会掉到地上。这太离奇了。哦，是的。金鱼。
Okay. I know about the goldfish, Jenna. It was in the shooting draft. It's a gift from AJ. What? Yes. There was a whole scene about it. And I have the clip from deleted scenes so you can hear it.
好的。我知道金鱼的事，珍娜。拍摄剧本里写了。那是AJ送的礼物。什么？是的。里面有一整段关于这个的戏。我有被删减片段的剪辑，所以你可以听听。
Hey, who's this? Oh, I had to get the rest of my stuff out of AJ's apartment. That's Fluffy. Fluffy. I like that. Hi, Fluffy. Hi, Fluffy. I never liked it.
嘿，这是谁？哦，我得把剩下的东西从AJ的公寓里搬出来。那是弗拉菲。弗拉菲。我喜欢这个名字。嗨，弗拉菲。嗨，弗拉菲。我从来没喜欢过它。
Oh. Well, the good thing about goldfish, they forget everything they know in two seconds so you could just rename them. You'd never know. Goldfinger. Goldschlager. Gold in my ear. Fluffy.
哦。好吧，金鱼的好处是，它们在两秒钟内就会忘记它们知道的一切，所以你可以直接给它们改个名字。你永远不会知道。金手指。金施拉格。我耳朵里的金子。弗拉菲。
Hates the name. I had one other background catch for Holly's desk. There is an unlit scented candle. Is it in a coffee cup? No. Oh. She brought her own candle. I guess the people who work in HR, sometimes they need to light a candle to relax.
讨厌这个名字。关于霍利的办公桌，我还有一个背景抓包。那里有一根没点燃的带香味的蜡烛。它在咖啡杯里吗？没有。哦。她带了自己的蜡烛。我猜在人力资源部门工作的人，有时他们需要点燃蜡烛来放松。
They need a mental health moment. At reception, we're going to start a new storyline. Pam is trying to get Erin's attention, but Erin is like obsessed with something on her phone. She's playing Scrabble with Gabe and she never wins. In the shooting draft, there was a Pam talking head here that explained her motivation for wanting to help Erin. Please share.
他们需要一个心理健康时刻。在前台，我们要开始一个新的故事情节。帕姆正试图引起厄兰的注意，但厄兰似乎对手机上的某个东西着迷了。她正在和盖布玩拼字游戏，而且从来没赢过。在拍摄剧本中，这里原本有一段帕姆面对镜头的独白，解释了她想要帮助厄兰的动机。请分享一下。
Pam says, I'm not letting Gabe do this. Jim and I used to play boggle against each other. Whenever he won, he was so cocky about it. It ruined boggle for me. It ruined words for me. Then, this would have cut to Jim and he would have said, yeah, I'm pretty good at boggle. And it says super cocky. Oh my gosh.
帕姆说：“我不会让盖比这么做的。吉姆和我以前经常一起玩拼字游戏。每次他赢了，他都会非常自傲。这毁了我的拼字游戏。这毁了我的词汇。”然后，这里本该切到吉姆，他会说：“对，我拼字游戏玩得挺好。”而且上面写着超级自傲。哦天哪。
Oh, I love that background. Well, Pam isn't the only person who's going to help Erin. Oscar's going to get involved as well. And I absolutely love filming scenes with Oscar. I love Pam and Oscar together. Whenever I see those two characters, I just want more of them. I love their dynamic. Same.
哦，我喜欢那个背景。好吧，帕姆并不是唯一一个准备帮艾琳的人。奥斯卡也参与进来了。我非常喜欢和奥斯卡一起拍戏。我喜欢帕姆和奥斯卡在一起。每当我看到这两个角色，我就只想看到更多他们的戏份。我喜欢他们的化学反应。我也是。
I mean, we go all the way back to the finer things club. Yes. We have a similar thing. Well, this whole storyline was based on a very real life thing that was happening on the set of the office, which was that we were obsessed with words with friends. Yes. It was the cast and the crew. We would sit in hair and makeup in the morning and we would do words with friends.
我是说，我们甚至可以追溯到精英文学俱乐部。是的。我们有类似的东西。好吧，整条故事线都是基于办公室片场发生的一件非常真实的事情，那就是我们沉迷于《与友同行》。是的。演员和剧组人员都沉迷其中。我们早上会坐在发型和化妆间里玩《与友同行》。
We would play each other. We would play strangers. Do you remember the scene? I so remember it. And I remember like Rain would trash talk quite a bit. Oh, yes. I would play Rain. Well, you know, a few years ago Rain and I played each other in Scrabble Go and I beat
我们会互相切磋。我们还会和陌生人玩。你还记得那个场景吗？我太记得了。我记得雷恩会说很多垃圾话。哦，是的。我会和雷恩对局。好吧，你知道，几年前雷恩和我一起玩《拼字游戏GO》，然后我击败了
him. I remember. I was so proud of you. He was so stunned. I was like, take that Rain. Well, I noticed we're not playing words with friends on the show. We're playing Scrabble. And I became curious, what is the difference between these two games?
他。我记得。我为你感到骄傲。他当时惊呆了。我说，接招吧，雷恩。好吧，我注意到我们在节目里玩的不是《与友同行》。我们玩的是《拼字游戏》。我开始好奇，这两个游戏有什么区别呢？
Is there a difference? Well, Words With Friends was an online app that then became a board game version that you can buy. It came out in 2009 and there's only a few differences. It's basically the layout of the bonus squares in Scrabble. They go in an X and then in Words With Friends, they're sort of scattered around. Yeah. And also, the point value of certain letters, like in Scrabble, the letter B is worth three
有什么区别吗？好吧，《与友同行》是一款在线应用程序，后来推出了可以购买的实体桌游版。它于2009年问世，只有几个区别。主要是《拼字游戏》中奖励格的布局。它们呈X形排列，而在《与友同行》中，它们是散落各处的。是的。还有，某些字母的分值不同，比如在《拼字游戏》中，字母B值三分，
points, but in Words With Friends, it's worth four points. I thought it was so interesting that you could just knock off a game and give it another name. And then... Well, you know my game that I love. What? Schmonopoly. I remember when you invented it.
但在《与友同行》中，它值四分。我觉得很有趣的一点是，你竟然可以直接抄袭一个游戏然后给它换个名字。然后……好吧，你知道我最爱的游戏是什么吗？什么？“山寨大富翁”。我记得你发明它的时候。
I was like, where did you think of this? I know. It just kind of came to me. It's amazing. You buy all these properties. Yeah. And I... Oh, the best.
当时我想：你是怎么想出这个来的？我知道。它就是自然而然地来到了我的脑海里。这太神奇了。你买下所有的房产。是的。然后我……哦，最棒的。
You got to get Ford Walk. Ford Walk is... You get a little car. Yeah. On Ford Walk. Amazing. And then there's a whole side that's like a bunch of wineries you can buy. You get little glasses of wine.
你得买福特步道。福特步道是……你会得到一辆小汽车。是的。在福特步道上。太神奇了。然后还有整整一边是你可以买的一堆酒庄。你会得到一小杯酒。
Schmonopoly. I love it. Well, Andy is scrambling. He needs to find people for his seminar now. Yeah, he's got people in the conference room waiting. He's going to ask Kevin to be his intro guy. Did you notice at six minutes and 41 seconds that you can see the top of my head as I sit at my desk?
“山寨大富翁”。我太喜欢了。好吧，安迪现在手忙脚乱的。他现在得为他的研讨会找人。是的，他会议室里有人在等。他打算让凯文当他的开场嘉宾。你有没有注意到，在六分四十一秒的时候，当我在座位上坐下时，你能看到我的头顶？
Yes, I did. Angela, I also noticed that's about all we see of you in this episode. Yeah, top of my head. I was having, I think, a pretty good part day. Like you couldn't see my cow lick. That's what I caught. Well, that's good. You might also ask yourself, Jenna, where was Meredith?
是的，我注意到了。安吉拉，我还注意到，这一集里你基本上也就露了这么多。是的，头顶。我觉得那天我的发型挺不错的。就像你看不到我的旋儿一样。这就是我注意到的。好吧，那挺好的。你可能也会自问，珍娜，梅雷迪思去哪儿了？
Oh, yes. Neither of the characters, Angela and Meredith, were on camera in this episode. But we did have lines in earlier drafts. Here were the scenes you did not see. OK. Meredith had one scene. She's going to find Dwight as he's trying to pump himself up for his speech at the top of the episode.
哦，是的。这两个角色，安吉拉和梅雷迪思，这一集里都没有出镜。但我们在早期的剧本草稿中确实有台词。以下是你没看到的场景。好的。梅雷迪思有一场戏。在本集开头，她发现德怀特正试图为他的演讲鼓舞士气。
You know, this is when he was still going to be the guest speaker. OK. This is how it was in the script. Exterior Dunder Mifflin parking lot. Meredith walks past Dwight's car, where she sees Dwight screaming a speech into his rear view mirror. Dwight says, ride the wind, jump the mountain, boil the ocean, hunt an angel, fly! Meredith yells at him, no one can hear you, idiot!
你知道，这是在他还要当特邀演讲嘉宾的时候。好的。剧本里是这样的。外景，邓德米夫林停车场。梅雷迪思走过德怀特的车旁，看到德怀特对着后视镜大声喊着演讲词。德怀特说：“乘风破浪，跨越群山，煮沸海洋，猎捕天使，飞翔！”梅雷迪思冲他大喊：“没人听得见你，笨蛋！”
That was Meredith's scene. Here was my scene. When Pam and Oscar are helping Aaron, Angela pops over. Oh! Mm-hmm. And then, just like this, Interior Office reception area. Pam, Oscar, and now Angela look over the desk at Aaron's phone. Angela says, it's not very polite for an unmarried woman to beat a man at a game.
那是梅雷迪思的场景。这是我的场景。当帕姆和奥斯卡在帮艾琳时，安吉拉突然冒了出来。哦！嗯——哼。然后，就像这样，内景，办公室接待区。帕姆、奥斯卡，现在还有安吉拉正隔着桌子看着艾琳的手机。安吉拉说：“未婚女子击败男士玩游戏，这可不太礼貌。”
Oh. She just pops in to throw some shade, and then she leaves. That's where Angela and Meredith would have been in the episode. I have a little bit of fan mail here that I'd like to call Welcome to the Party, Ashley C from Perth in Australia. And I mean that genuinely, Ashley, because like me, it took you until this episode to notice that Angela has a pelican on top of her divider. And Ashley, thank you.
哦。她突然出现泼了点冷水，然后就离开了。这就是安吉拉和梅雷迪思原本会在这一集里出现的地方。我这里有一封粉丝来信，我想把它叫做“欢迎来到派对，来自澳大利亚珀斯的阿什利·C”。我是真心实意的，阿什利，因为像我一样，你直到这一集才注意到安吉拉的隔板顶部有一只鹈鹕。阿什利，谢谢你。
Thank you for being with me on this journey of not noticing that until Season 7, late in the game, Ashley said I love pelicans, and I was wondering if there was a story behind it or just completely random. It's completely random, but since I'm throwing out a few, there is no spoons. Okay. Let me throw this, Asha, Ashley and Jenna. What if the pelican is Kevin's? Oh, wow.
谢谢你陪我一起经历这个直到第七季快结束才注意到这一点的旅程。阿什利说我喜欢鹈鹕，我想知道这背后有什么故事，还是完全随机的。这完全是随机的，不过既然我要爆料几个，那就是没有勺子。好吧。让我来抛出这个假设，阿什利和珍娜。如果这只鹈鹕是凯文的呢？哦，哇。
But he faced it toward you? Yes, to antagonize me, I don't know. So it stares at her all day. Ashley, from the bottom of my heart, thank you for your fan catch in this episode. Yes, Ashley, welcome to the pelican party. Mm-hmm. Andy is still scrambling. He's going to now go to Ryan.
但它的脸朝向你？对呀，是为了挑衅我，我不知道。所以它整天盯着她。阿什利，发自内心地感谢你在这一集中捕捉到的粉丝彩蛋。是的，阿什利，欢迎来到鹈鹕派对。嗯——哼。安吉拉……安迪还在手忙脚乱。他现在要去找瑞恩了。
Ryan has a business degree. Maybe Ryan could say something at the seminar. Listen, he'll do it. He doesn't like to commit to things, but he'll do it. But he also doesn't not like committing to things. Yeah. Both are a form of commitment. Here's the thing.
瑞恩有商业学位。也许瑞恩可以在研讨会上说点什么。听着，他会去的。他不喜欢对事情做出承诺，但他会去的。但他也不讨厌对事情做出承诺。是的。这两种都是承诺的形式。事情是这样的。
If he flakes, he flakes. Yeah. At 7 minutes 22 seconds over Kelly's shoulder, because she's also in this scene, you can see her print in all colors certificate of completion. Hey. It's right there on the wall. Next up, let's call this pep talk in the break room. Okay.
如果他放鸽子，他就放鸽子。是的。在七分二十二秒时，在凯莉的肩膀上方，因为她也在这场戏里，你能看到她全彩打印的结业证书。嘿。它就挂在那边的墙上。接下来，我们把这叫做休息室里的打气。好吧。
Because Andy really needs to get this group like, on fire, they need to sell stuff. He's got Kevin, he's got Ryan, he's got Creed. There was more to this scene in the shooting draft where they talk out who is going to do what. Okay. There's a candy bag alt when Creed pitches himself to Andy. Okay. This made me laugh so hard.
因为安迪真的需要让这群人像打了鸡血一样，他们需要卖东西。他有凯文，他有瑞恩，他有克里德。拍摄剧本中关于这场戏还有更多内容，他们讨论了谁将做什。好吧。当克里德向安迪推销自己时，有一个糖果袋备选桥段。好吧。这把我笑得不行。
You're laughing. I know. You can't even read it. Creed says, way I see it, you're trapped in a room of your own making. But there's a door and the name on that door is Creed. I'll be your guest speaker. I might not be as good as Dwight, but I guarantee it will be the most thought provoking, hilarious moving six hours of their lives.
你在笑。我知道。你甚至都读不下去。克里德说：“依我看，你被困在一个自己造的房间里。但有一扇门，那扇门上的名字叫克里德。我来当你的特邀演讲嘉宾。我可能不如德怀特那么优秀，但我保证这将是他们一生中最耐人寻味、最搞笑、最感人的六个小时。”
Six hours. I have a big question. Yes. Here's my question. What is happening in the conference room while Andy is making all of these plans with people? Why are these people sitting in our conference room for all of this dead space? What is it? I mean, it was a big logic loophole for me.
六个小时。我有一个大问题。是的。我的问题是：当安迪在和大家做所有这些计划时，会议室里到底在发生什么？为什么这些人要坐在我们的会议室里度过所有这些空白时间？这到底是什么？我是说，对我来说这是一个巨大的逻辑漏洞。
That they wouldn't just leave? Yes. That clearly, clearly this is not going to be a great seminar. I can see it. Can you see it? Why are these people also, it hasn't started on time clearly, so anything where you're going to give me a bunch of advice, if you can't start on time, I'm immediately suspicious. You know what I'm saying?
他们怎么不直接离开？是的。很明显，很明显这不会是一个很好的研讨会。我能看出来。你能看出来吗？为什么这些人——而且，它明显没有按时开始，所以任何要给你一堆建议的活动，如果连按时开始都做不到，我立刻就会起疑心。你知道我在说什么吗？
I hear you. I want to throw this at you. Free lunch. I think some of them are just there for the free lunch and the lady on the front row is there to pitch possibilities. You know what I'm saying? Okay. Free lunch.
我懂。我想抛出这个给你。免费午餐。我觉得他们有些人只是为了免费午餐，而前排的那位女士是为了推销潜在可能。你知道我在说什么吗？好吧。免费午餐。
I'm taking a round for the free lunch. All right. I'll take it. Speaking of free lunch, I could use a snack. Why don't we take a break and when we get back, the seminar starts. And my favorite line of the entire episode is going to happen. Oh, I can't wait to hear what it is. I have some guesses.
为了免费午餐我豁出去了。好吧。我接受。说到免费午餐，我正想吃点零食。我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，研讨会就要开始了。而整集中我最喜欢的台词就要发生了。哦，我等不及想听听是什么了。我来猜猜。
Okay. All right, we are back. The lady is finally going to kick off this seminar, Angela, what is your favorite line? Okay. I loved it so much. I had to go to the shooting draft to see if it was worded this way. It was. We just have to hear it.
好吧。好了，我们回来了。这位女士终于要开始这个研讨会了，安吉拉，你最喜欢的台词是什么？好吧。我太喜欢了。我不得不去查阅拍摄剧本，看看它是不是这样措辞的。确实是。我们必须听一听。
I just love it. I love this line. I don't know what's wrong with me. I love it. Hi, Nard Dog. I'm Lou Peacham. Is that it? Yes.
我太喜欢了。我太喜欢这句台词了。我不知道自己怎么了。我太喜欢了。嗨，纳德狗。我是露·佩查姆。就是这个吗？是的。
Hi, Nard Dog. I'm Lou Peacham. Yes. Angela, we got so much mail about that. This is my favorite line. She's so happy. She immediately says her name in the shooting draft. It was written, Hi, Nard Dog.
嗨，纳德狗。我是露·佩查姆。是的。安吉拉，我们收到了好多关于这个的邮件。这是我最喜欢的台词。她太开心了。她在拍摄剧本里直接说出了自己的名字。剧本上写的是：嗨，纳德狗。
I'm Lou Peacham exclamation point. Okay. First of all, Selena F. from Chandler, Arizona said, I have to know more about the woman who plays Lou Peacham. Her delivery of her single line is hilarious. I laugh every time it comes up. And Molly A. from the United Kingdom said, that line is my most quoted office line. Please tell me if there is a backstory to this iconic queen.
我是露·佩查姆，感叹号。好吧。首先，来自亚利桑那州钱德勒的塞莱娜·F说，我必须了解更多关于扮演露·佩查姆的这位女演员的信息。她对这句简短台词的演绎太爆笑了。每次出现我都会笑。来自英国的莫莉·A说，那句台词是我引用最多的办公室金句。请告诉我这个标志性的女王背后有没有什么背景故事。
I mean, after hearing her say, Hi, Nard Dog, I'm Lou Peacham. I really need to hear her say, how about post-stabilities? I agree with you, Angela. I love Lou Peacham. I have a guest star breakdown. Lou Peacham was played by Janet Hoskins. She has also appeared in New Girl. It's always sunny in Philadelphia.
我是说，听完她说“嗨，纳德狗，我是露·佩查姆”，我真的很想听她说“后稳定性怎么样？”我同意你的看法，安吉拉。我太喜欢露·佩查姆了。我有一个客串演员资料。露·佩查姆由珍妮特·霍斯金斯饰演。她还出演过《杰茜驾到》、《费城永远艳阳高照》、
The comeback and Mindy Kaling's show that she created with Justin Noble, the sex lives of college girls, which by the way, the new season is out right now on HBO. Max, I am living for it. I love this show. I love the show. And I mean, we've said how talented Justin is and Mindy and the two of them coming together. I was like, this is going to be really good. I wish this show was around when I was a college girl.
《归来记》，以及敏迪·卡灵与贾斯汀·诺贝尔共同创作的秀《大学女生的性生活》，顺便说一句，新季现在已经在HBO Max上播出了，我简直太期待了。我太喜欢这个节目了。我太喜欢这个节目了。我是说，我们已经说过贾斯汀和敏迪是多么有才华，当他们两人聚在一起时，我想：这肯定会非常好看。我真希望当我还是个大学女生的时候这个节目就已经有了。
It is. Oh my gosh. I really do. That's all I can say. Yeah. I looked at the shooting draft, the table draft, every draft I could find to see if there was more for Lou Peacham. And that's all it said.
确实有。哦天哪。我真的这么觉得。这就是我能说的全部了。是的。我看了拍摄剧本、围读剧本、我能找到的所有剧本，想看看露·佩查姆还有没有更多戏份。但剧本里就写了这么多。
There were no candy bag alts, but her delivery of Heinar Dogheim Lou Peacham is the best. Next up, eight minutes, 26 seconds, Kevin is going to hit play on a boombox. And we hear a very long musical introduction. It is Ozzy Osbourne's Crazy Train. I loved it. Randy told me that we licensed that song for $50,000. Whoa. Yeah.
没有什么糖果袋备选桥段，但她对“嗨，纳德狗我是露·佩查姆”的演绎简直是绝了。接下来，八分二十六秒，凯文按下了一个收音机的播放键。我们听到了一段非常漫长的音乐前奏。那是奥兹·奥斯本的《疯狂列车》。我太喜欢了。兰迪告诉我，我们花50,000美元买下了这首歌的版权。哇。是的。
I guess it was originally scripted to be Van Halen's right now, but the Van Halen people got back to us and said it would be $100,000 to use their song. So Randy went back to Steve Healy, the writer, and asked if we could get some maybe alternatives. And here was his list ranked in order of preference. Number one, Wanted Man by Rat, Crazy Train, Ozzy Osbourne, Baba O'Reilly the Who, Down Boys by Warrant, and Nothing but a Good Time by Poison. Oh, I loved some poison back in the day. Randy said we were given permission for Wanted Man.
我猜原本剧本里定的是范·海伦的《就是现在》，但范·海伦的人回复我们说使用他们的歌需要10,0000美元。所以兰迪回到编剧史蒂夫·希利那里，问我们能不能找点备选歌曲。这是他的备选清单，按偏好顺序排列：第一名，雷特乐队的《被通缉的人》，《疯狂列车》奥兹·奥斯本，谁人乐队的《巴巴·奥赖利》，华伦乐队的《下流男孩》，还有毒药乐队的《唯有美好时光》。哦，我以前挺喜欢毒药乐队的。兰迪说我们获得了《被通缉的人》的使用许可。
That would have been $50,000 as well. But in the end, they really liked the idea of Crazy Train by Ozzy Osbourne. And that's how we got that song. I thought it was perfect. I could see Kevin thinking that that was the right song to pump everyone up. Yeah, I agree. All of those songs are great and funny for like an introduction in this scenario. But if you add the piece that Kevin had to think of it, I think Crazy Train is the choice.
那也要50,000美元。但最后，他们真的很喜欢奥兹·奥斯本的《疯狂列车》这个主意。这就是我们选这首歌的原因。我觉得完美极了。我能想象凯文觉得这正是能让每个人热血沸腾的正确歌曲。是的，我同意。所有这些歌曲都很棒，对于这种场景下的开场来说也很搞笑。但如果你加上凯文必须自己想到这一点这个前提，我觉得《疯狂列车》就是不二之选。
I thought Brian just crushed the scene. This was my favorite part of the episode was Brian. Yes. Kevin and Lou Peachum. Yes. This scene. And also maybe Creed. Oh, yes.
我觉得布莱恩这场戏演得太棒了。这是这一集中我最喜欢的部分，就是布莱恩。是的。凯文和露·佩查姆。是的。这场戏。还有可能是克里德。哦，是的。
Creed, we'll get to it. We'll get to it. At nine minutes and 30 seconds, I was really curious about Kevin's speech. He's talking about dreaming big. And he has a line after he sits on the floor where he says, okay, from here now. And he continues his speech. It really made me laugh and it felt like an improv to me. So I went to the shooting draft and that line is not in there.
克里德，我们一会儿会聊到。我们一会儿会聊到的。在九分三十秒时，我对凯文的演讲非常好奇。他在谈论怀揣大梦想。当他坐在地板上之后，他有一句台词，他说：“好吧，从现在开始。”然后他继续他的演讲。这真的把我逗笑了，感觉像是即兴发挥。所以我去看了拍摄剧本，那句台词并不在里面。
Wow. Brian improvised that line. In the script, it just said, Andy says, you okay? And Kevin says, I'm fine. Still sitting continues speech. Wow. So yeah, the okay from here now. To me, it sounded so resigned, but he was going to keep speaking.
哇。布莱恩即兴发挥了那句台词。在剧本里，只写着：安迪说：“你没事吧？”然后凯文说：“我没事。”依然坐着，继续演讲。哇。所以，那个“好吧，从现在开始”。在我听来，显得非常无奈，但他还是要继续演讲。
Next up is going to be Ryan. How do you follow the guy that just puked and ran around the room and ate a sandwich and then ran out the door? Ryan's not going to have to worry about it because Kelly bursts in because she's the business bitch. That's right. She has a talking head where she says it's important to brand yourself. So I have a couple of things in the works, the business bitch, the diet bitch, the shopping
接下来轮到瑞恩了。你怎么能接在那个刚吐过、在房间里乱跑、吃了个三明治然后冲出门去的家伙后面呢？瑞恩不用担心这个，因为凯莉冲了进来，因为她是商界碧池。没错。她有一个访谈，在里面她说自我品牌塑造很重要。所以我手头有几个计划，商界碧池、减肥碧池、购物
bitch, the etiquette bitch. I had to know if there was more to this talking head. Was there? There were no candy bag alts for it, but it was a longer talking head in the shooting draft. It would have read like this. I'm trying to brand myself. I've got a couple of ideas, the business bitch, the shopping bitch, the advice bitch,
碧池、礼仪碧池。我必须知道这个访谈还有没有更多内容。有吗？没有糖果袋备选，但在拍摄剧本里，这是一个更长的访谈。内容是这样的：我正在努力打造自己的品牌。我有一些想法，商界碧池、购物碧池、咨询碧池、
the diet bitch, the etiquette bitch. I'm also writing a memoir. I'm a bitch, deal with it bitch, which is a separate enterprise. I Googled the business bitch. I was curious if anyone had taken this brand and taken off with it. I couldn't find anything. I was very surprised, but I did find a bumper sticker that says, I'm not the business bitch. I'm the business bitch.
减肥碧池、礼仪碧池。我还正在写一本回忆录。我是个碧池，接受现实吧碧池，这是一个独立的业务。我谷歌了一下“商界碧池”。我很想知道是否有人已经占用了这个品牌并将其发扬光大。我什么都没找到。我很吃惊，但我确实找到了一个贴纸，上面写着：我不是商界碧池。我是商界碧池。
Yeah, a little spin on it. Yeah. Kelly's going to say that she could tell them the 10 secrets of business and they would learn a lot. But instead, she's going to call Professor Scott Powell, Yale University adjunct professor in management. They can hear it straight from Scott Powell. Professor Powell really comes through.
对，稍微旋转了一下。是的。凯莉说她可以告诉他们商业的十个秘密，他们能学到很多。但相反，她要请出斯科特·鲍尔教授，耶鲁大学管理学兼职教授。他们可以直接听听斯科特·鲍尔的讲解。鲍尔教授真的很给力。
He starts talking and everyone is very impressed, starts jotting down his notes. This is officially the only moment in this whole seminar that might be useful. Andy has a talking head afterwards where he's very impressed and he says, that brilliant little bitch. Yeah. It's a candy bag alt. Really? Andy would have said this, again, very impressed.
他开始讲话，大家都很impress，开始记笔记。这绝对是整个研讨会中唯一可能有点用处的时刻。安迪随后来了一个访谈，他非常impress，并说：“那个才华横溢的小碧池。”是的。这是一个糖果袋备选。真的吗？安迪本会这样说，再次强调，非常impress。
I always kind of thought of myself as the business bitch, but after today, Kelly can have it. I like that one. Back at front reception, Oscar, Aaron and Pam are still trying to beat Gabe and Scrabble. This scene has maybe my favorite Pam and Oscar couplet of dialogue. Oh yeah? Mm-hmm. When Pam says, you could have just told us what you were thinking and Oscar says, yeah,
我一直觉得自己才算商界碧池，但今天之后，凯莉可以拿去。我喜欢这个。回到前台接待处，奥斯卡、艾琳和帕姆仍然在试图在拼字游戏中击败盖比。这场戏里有我最喜欢的帕姆和奥斯卡对话。哦是吗？嗯——哼。当帕姆说：“你本可以直接告诉我们你在想什么。”奥斯卡说：“对，
there's no theater in that and Pam says, there's no yelling in that either. Oh yeah, I did like that line. We had a fan question from ML in Toronto, Ontario, who said, while watching this episode, I absolutely loved the Scrabble storyline with Aaron, Oscar and Pam. I think this was the episode that made me realize how similar I am to Oscar. Oh yeah? If I was in this situation, I would definitely be the Oscar. That's the one that's way too into the game, starts getting impatient and is definitely
那样就没有任何戏剧性了。”帕姆说：“那样也没有人会大喊大叫。”哦，对了，我确实喜欢那句台词。我们收到了来自安大略省多伦多的ML的粉丝提问，她说：在看这一集时，我非常喜欢艾琳、奥斯卡和帕姆的拼字游戏故事线。我觉得正是这一集让我意识到我和奥斯卡有多么相似。哦是吗？如果我处于这种情况下，我绝对会成为奥斯卡。就是那种对游戏太投入、开始变得不耐烦并且绝对
capable of winning. My question to you is, who would you be in this group? Would you be the Aaron who kind of sucks at the game, the Pam who just wants to help and is there to have fun, or the Oscar, the one that needs to win? Oh, I'm a Pam Oscar combo. Yeah, I vacillate between Pam and Oscar. I'm very competitive in games and sometimes it's hard for me with my kids. To tone it down?
有能力赢的人。我的问题是：在这个组合里你会是谁？你会是那个游戏玩得有点烂的艾琳，还是只想帮忙、去那儿玩得开心的帕姆，抑或是那个必须赢的奥斯卡？哦，我是帕姆和奥斯卡的结合体。是的，我在帕姆和奥斯卡之间摇摆不定。我在游戏中好胜心极强，有时这让我在面对我的孩子们时很难办。收敛一点？
A little bit, because I don't want to model bad behavior, but when my sister and I were young and we would play games with each other, the winner got to sing a song to the loser. Oh yeah? Yeah. This is an interesting family tradition. It went like this, I'm the winner, I'm the winner, you're the loser, you're the loser, I'm the winner, winner, winner, winner, loser, loser. Oh my God.
稍微收敛一点，因为我不想树立不良行为的榜样，但当我和我姐姐小的时候，我们经常一起玩游戏，赢的人可以给输的人唱首歌。哦是吗？是的。这是一个有趣的家庭传统。它是这样的：我是赢家，我是赢家，你是输家，你是输家，我是赢家，赢家，赢家，赢家，输家，输家。哦天哪。
It's so fast. You know what, as you did it, you went back in time. I did. I have so many memories of us being, we mostly played games at Lake of the Ozarks. We would go down every summer, my parents had a cabin there and we would spend a lot of time together playing games. I have memories of sitting in our little kitchen at Lake of the Ozarks and singing that song or having the song sung to me.
节奏好快。你知道吗，当你唱出来的时候，你仿佛回到了过去。我确实回去了。我有太多我们在一起的回忆，我们大部分时间都在奥沙克湖玩游戏。我们每年夏天都会去，我父母在那里有一个小木屋，我们会花很多时间一起玩游戏。我有在奥沙克湖的小厨房里唱那首歌或者听别人对我唱那首歌的回忆。
My parents did not like it. There's maybe one of the places where I got such a competitive streak other than my mom. I was playing tennis in high school and my coach was Coach Lunn and he would say to me after a game, because he had multiple games he would have to be watching, you know, so he'd make his rounds and if he wasn't able to see the end of my game, he would just come up to me and say, Kenzie, victory or death? If I had lost, I'd be like, death coach. Oh my gosh, victory or death.
我父母其实并不喜欢它。这也许是我身上那种强烈好胜心的来源之一，除了遗传我妈妈。我上高中时打网球，我的教练是伦恩教练，他在一场比赛结束后会对我说——因为他要看好几场比赛，所以他得四处巡视——你知道的，如果他没能看到我比赛的结束，他就会走到我面前说：“肯齐，胜利还是死亡？”如果我输了，我就会说：“死亡，教练。”哦天哪，胜利还是死亡。
Yeah. Wow. I learned as an adult that you're supposed to be more, I don't know, what would you call it? Gracious? Yes. Exactly. When playing games with people, if you win, it was a learned skill.
是的。哇。我长大后才明白，你应该表现得更有——我不知道，你管这叫什么？风度吗？是的。没错。和别人一起玩游戏时，如果你赢了，这其实是一项需要学习的技能。
I guess I started as an Oscar and I've tried to move more toward a Pam. I'm realizing you and I have never played a game one-on-one. We've done group games like at the Super Bowl, we do bingo, but we haven't really done a game where we might have to sing loser to each other. I mean, I want to be your friend, so I've maybe actively avoided playing this game with you. Avoid this moment. Mm-hmm.
我想我一开始是个奥斯卡，然后我一直在努力向帕姆靠拢。我突然意识到你和我从来没有单独玩过游戏。我们玩过团体游戏，比如在超级碗的时候，我们玩宾果，但我们确实没怎么玩过那种可能需要对彼此唱输家之歌的游戏。我是说，我想做你的朋友，所以我可能一直在刻意避免和你玩这个游戏。避免这个时刻。嗯——哼。
All right. Where are we? Oh, Holly and Mika Nos are hanging out with Hank in the lobby. Yeah, at caffeine corner and guess what, Holly decides to participate. Yeah. She's going to be a character with Michael. It's very sweet. He's going to have a talking head where she looks at Cameron and says, I don't know.
好吧。我们到哪儿了？哦，霍莉和米卡诺斯正和大堂里的汉克在一起。是的，在咖啡角，你猜怎么着，霍莉决定参与进来。是的。她要和迈克尔一起成为一个角色。这太甜了。他会有一个访谈，在里面她看着卡梅伦说：“我不知道。”
And she's smiling. He's getting through. Andy is now going to introduce Creed, his special guest speaker. Creed walks up to the front of the conference room and says, two eyes, two ears, a chin, a mouth, 10 fingers, two nipples, a butt, two kneecaps, a penis. I have just described to you the Loch Ness monster and the reward for his capture, all the riches in Scotland. So I have one question.
而且她在笑。他成功打动她了。安迪现在要介绍他的特邀演讲嘉宾克里德了。克里德走到会议室前面说：“两只眼睛，两只耳朵，一个下巴，一张嘴，十个手指，两个乳头，一个屁股，两个膝盖骨，一个阴茎。我刚刚向你们描述了尼斯湖水怪以及抓捕它的悬赏——苏格兰所有的财富。所以我有一个问题。
Why are you here? Angela, we had a fan catch from Walker D in Evanston, Illinois. Who says this? This is the only thing I had to write about in the whole series. Oh my goodness. What? In gossip, Creed says, if I can't scuba, then what's this all been about? What am I working toward?
你们为什么在这里？”安吉拉，我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州埃文斯顿的沃克·D的粉丝彩蛋。他是这么说的：这是我在整部剧里唯一需要写信吐槽的地方。哦天哪。什么？在八卦那一集里，克里德说：“如果我不能潜水，那这一切都是为了什么？我到底在为什么努力？”
And then he has this speech in the seminar. I think we're finally learning why scuba is so important to him because he wants to hunt down the Loch Ness monster for a reward. It's art at its finest. I like that. I love that Walker made that connection between scuba and this speech about the Loch Ness monster. Well, Walker, get ready for this.
然后他在研讨会上有了这段演讲。我觉得我们终于知道为什么潜水对他这么重要了，因为他想去猎捕尼斯湖水怪来换取悬赏。这是艺术的最高境界。我喜欢这个。我太喜欢沃克把潜水和这段关于尼斯湖水怪的演讲联系起来了。好吧，沃克，准备好迎接这个吧。
There was a candy bag alt. It actually was filmed. It was in deleted scenes. Here's another version of what Creed says to the room of people. A number of years ago, I was telling a friend an idea I had for a restaurant where kids could play games and watch shows. Sounds a lot like Chuck E. Cheese, right? Well the guy who invented Chuck E. Cheese was sitting at the next table.
还有一个糖果袋备选。它其实拍了。它在被删减片段里。这是克里德对满屋子人说的另一版台词。多年前，我曾向一位朋友透露过一个开餐厅的想法，在那里孩子们可以玩游戏、看节目。听起来很像查奇芝士，对吧？好吧，发明查奇芝士的那个人就坐在隔壁桌。
I have evidence, affidavits and documents that they locked me out of the deal. And someday his day will come with the craziest thing about all this, the rest of where it took place, Chuck E. Cheese. Was your idea also called Chuck E. Cheese? Nope. It's called Woodstock's Freakout Zone. What was that? Exactly.
我有证据、宣誓书和文件，证明他们把我排除在交易之外。总有一天他会遭到报应的，而这一切最疯狂的地方在于，事件发生的地方就是查奇芝士。你的想法也叫查奇芝士吗？不。它叫伍德斯托克的疯狂地带。那是什么？没错。
Exactly. The camera pans over to Andy and Andy just looks like he wants to disappear into the floor. Have we discussed my idea for a business called Date Night? No, we haven't. Are you sure you want to give it up? Well, hear me out. Okay.
没错。镜头摇向安迪，安迪看起来只想在地板上挖个洞钻进去。我们讨论过我那个叫“约会之夜”的生意想法吗？没有，我们没有。你确定你要放弃它吗？好吧，听我解释。好吧。
So it's a business and what you get is just a room with a couch, a really cozy couch. And like a room service menu. There's a TV and it has a cable box thing and you can sign into anything you want. Netflix, HBO Max, you have to sign in on your account. This keeps it legal. But basically if you're a parent, the idea is that you can go there for Date Night, they'll bring you food and you can just binge your favorite show with your partner. So instead of a hotel room, it's just like a room full of living rooms and you get to
所以这是一个生意，你得到的是一个只有一张沙发、一张非常舒适的沙发的房间。还有一个客房服务菜单。里面有一台电视和一个机顶盒，你可以登录任何你想用的东西。Netflix、HBO Max，你得登录你自己的账号。这样合法。但基本上如果你是个父母，这个想法就是你可以去那里过约会之夜，他们会给你送吃的，然后你可以和你的伴侣一起狂刷你最喜欢的节目。所以与其说是一个酒店房间，不如说是一个摆满客厅的房间，你可以
pick the living room you want. Maybe you want a sectional. Maybe you want two side-by-side recliner. Yes. There's options. Yeah. It's cheaper than a hotel room, you know, because it's just a bunch of living rooms and you don't stay there overnight.
挑选你想要的客厅。也许你想要一个转角沙发。也许你想要两个并排的躺椅。是的。有各种选择。是的。比酒店房间便宜，你知道的，因为这只是一堆客厅，而且你不在那儿过夜。
You get it for like four hours. You just binge and eat. I think those are called motels. No, no, because you can't go to a motel and log into HBO Max. It's true. You know what I'm saying? There are places you can rent by the hour. They're not maybe a living room experience.
你租个四小时左右。你就只管狂刷和吃东西。我觉得那叫汽车旅馆。不，不，因为你不能去汽车旅馆登录HBO Max。确实如此。你知道我在说什么吗？有些地方你可以按小时租。它们可能不是客厅体验。
This is not about sex. This is about food and entertainment. Okay. This is about eating and watching your show uninterrupted. Right. You're not getting snacks for anybody. No. You're doing no dishes.
这不是关于性。这是关于食物和娱乐。好的。这是关于吃东西和不间断地看你的节目。没错。你不用给任何人拿零食。不用。你不用洗碗。
No dishes. You're putting your feet up and you're watching a show. Yes. With your special person. Whatever the thing is that you haven't been able to finish at home. You get to finish it at Date Night. It's called Date Night. You make a reservation.
不用洗碗。你翘起二郎腿看着节目。是的。和你的特别的人一起。无论你在家里一直没看完的是什么。你都可以在“约会之夜”看完它。它叫“约会之夜”。你做个预约。
You pick out your living room. Yes. They take AARP. AARP. Isn't that like what the older people? The official old people card. Yes. Official old people card where you get discounts on movies.
你挑选你的客厅。是的。他们接受AARP（美国退休人员协会）。AARP。那不是老年人专属的吗？官方的老年人卡。是的。官方的老年人卡，看电影可以打折。
That's how you know when you get that in the mail, it hurts your feelings. My dad loved his AARP card. You could get a discount at movies and things. I'm just saying. I think it's brilliant. I would go to Date Night. Right? Yeah.
这就是你怎么知道当你收到那个信件时，你的自尊心受到了伤害。我爸爸可喜欢他的AARP卡了。你看电影和其他东西都可以打折。我只是随口一说。我觉得这太绝了。我会去“约会之夜”。对吧？是的。
You know. But there's a rule. You're not supposed to get sexy in there. It's for, you know, we don't have time to like turn over. There's a room. There's rules. We don't have. Yes.
你知道的。但有个规则。你们不准在里面搞色情。这是为了，你知道的，我们没时间去换场。有个房间。有规则。我们没有。是的。
Yeah. It's not about that. It's not about that. It's about just watching a program with your special person and maybe having like some French fries. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
是的。这不是关于那个。这不是关于那个。这是关于和你的特别的人一起看节目，可能吃点薯条什么的。是的。没错。是的。
There'd be good food. There are so many possibilities for this. I think this business could really take off. You know what, Jenna? I am here for you. When you get it up and running, I'm going to rent a living room. Thank you. Okay.
那里会有好吃的。这个想法有太多可能性了。我觉得这门生意真的能火。你知道吗，珍娜？我支持你。等你把它开起来，我要去租个客厅。谢谢。好吧。
Let me know. I'll bring my AARP card. I think I'm eligible. But don't get sexy in there. Oh. Okay. Okay. You have to do that at home before you get there or after.
告诉我。我会带上我的AARP卡。我觉得我有资格。但别在里面搞色情哦。哦。好吧。好吧。你得在去之前或者回家之后在家里搞定那个。
Okay. And we serve liquor. What are you, what are you going to get? Two people are alone who never get to be alone. You're going to give them liquor and then say, don't mess around. Exactly what they're going to do is mess around. Sorry. Maybe we need to rethink it.
好吧。而且我们提供酒水。你打算——你打算提供什么？两个从没有独处机会的人独自在一起。你要给他们提供酒水，然后告诉他们：别胡闹。他们绝对会做的就是胡闹。抱歉。也许我们需要重新考虑一下。
People are going to have a little action on your sofa. Sorry. Well, we're not going to put a bed in there. Okay. So you're going to have to figure it out. All right. Where are we in this episode? Gabe has selected his next movie.
人们会在你的沙发上搞点事情的。抱歉。好吧，我们不在里面放床。好吧。所以你们得自己想办法。好了。我们在这一集到哪儿了？盖比选好了他的下一部电影。
His next scary movie. Aaron doesn't like scary movies and he keeps picking these creepy movies. His next movie is Suspiria. She wanted Wally. First of all, did you see Pam eavesdropping in the background on this conversation that was scripted? Mm-hmm. Pam's supposed to be overhearing how this is going.
他的下一部恐怖电影。艾琳不喜欢恐怖电影，但他一直挑这些惊悚的电影。他的下一部电影是《阴风阵阵》。她原本想要《机器人瓦力》。首先，你看到帕姆在背景里偷听这场被编剧写进剧本的对话了吗？嗯——哼。帕姆本该偷听到进展如何。
That's probably part of her boggle storyline that we missed. I looked up Suspiria. It's a 1977 Italian supernatural horror film. It was remade recently, but here's the description that was on my TV for the original. I've not seen it and I was intrigued, widely considered to be the most shocking and hallucinatory horror movie in history. No, thank you. It was described by the director as, quote, an escalating experimental nightmare.
这可能是她错过的拼字游戏剧情的一部分。我查了一下《阴风阵阵》。这是一部1977年的意大利超自然恐怖电影。它最近被翻拍了，这是我电视上对原版的描述。我没看过，但我被吸引了，它被广泛认为是历史上最具震撼力和幻觉色彩的恐怖电影。不，谢谢。导演将其形容为：引文，一场不断升级的实验性噩梦。
No, thank you. And it's part of a trilogy. You love a trilogy. Not this kind of trilogy. The trilogy includes Inferno and The Mother of Tears. Why would I say, oh, you know what I'm going to do tonight? I want to watch Mother of Tears. I don't know.
不，谢谢。它是三部曲的一部分。你最喜欢三部曲了。不是这种三部曲。这个三部曲包括《地狱》和《泪之母》。我为什么会说：“哦，你知道我今晚要干嘛吗？我想看《泪之母》。”我不知道。
But when the film was released in America, they had to cut out eight minutes of it so that it could get an R rating. Otherwise, it would have been like an X rating or an NR rating. No, thank you. It has a 93% on Rotten Tomatoes and it is ranked number 61 on their list of top 100 horror films. Guess what's number one? I have no idea.
但当这部电影在美国上映时，他们不得不剪掉了八分钟的内容，以便获得R级评级。否则它就会被评为X级或者无评级。不，谢谢。它在烂番茄上有93%的好评率，并在其百大恐怖电影榜单上排名第61位。你猜第1名是什么？我不知道。
Psycho. Okay. I tried to watch it. Can't find it anywhere because they did the remake, so that's all over streaming. You know what? What? Maybe at date night up and running, I'm going to figure out how to play Suspiria. Well, that sounds like a wonderful date night.
《惊魂记》。好吧。我试着找来看过。到处都找不到，因为他们拍了翻拍版，所以流媒体上到处都是翻拍版。你知道吗？什么？也许等“约会之夜”开张了，我要想办法放映《阴风阵阵》。好吧，听起来真是个美妙的约会之夜。
Oh, no. You should take Gabe. Dwight is going to start chatting up. Tuba. Tuba's back. Yes. Remember our script supervisor, Vada. Her husband appeared in an episode previously.
哦，不。你应该带盖比去。德怀特开始搭讪了。图巴。图巴回来了。是的。还记得我们的剧务瓦达吗。她的丈夫之前在一集里出现过。
He is back. He is golf guy. And he has sat down at Jim's desk and is just using Jim's computer. What? I mean, golf guy's very comfortable. He's also been there for hours with nothing happening. I mean, don't get me started on that. Dwight's going to realize that some of these people are for real.
他回来了。他是高尔夫男。他坐在吉姆的桌子上，直接用起了吉姆的电脑。什么？我是说，高尔夫男可真不客气。他在那儿坐了好几个小时什么也没干。我是说，别让我开启这个话题。德怀特意识到这些人是来真的了。
He's going to get Phyllis and Stanley in the kitchen. They're going to go up to Andy and Dwight, who thinks he's so smooth, goes, hey friend, how's it going? Oh, you know what? Let me steep that for you. Angela, is there any possibility that you were able to zoom in on the cup that Andy is making his tea in, and you figured out what it said, and you're going to tell me all about it?
他把菲利丝和斯坦利叫到厨房。他们走向安迪和德怀特，德怀特自作聪明地说：“嘿，朋友，最近怎么样？哦，你知道吗？让我来帮你泡一下。”安吉拉，你有没有可能把安迪泡茶的杯子放大，然后弄清楚上面写的是什么，接着你就要告诉我这一切？
No. You say no as if I would never do that, but I'm sorry. Did we not have a major breakdown about the hot dog people? Pony Island lunch. Yeah. Here's the thing. She's talking about Dwight's coffee mug that he holds with his feet. I probably would have done that, Jenna, if I wasn't so thrown by this line, let me steep
没有。你回答“没有”的语气，好像我绝不会干那种事一样，但我很抱歉。难道我们没有对热狗人做过重大解析吗？小马岛午餐。是的。事情是这样的。她在说德怀特用脚拿着的那个咖啡杯。我本来可能会去查的，珍娜，如果我没有被这句台词惊到的话：“让我来帮你泡一下。”
that for you. I became obsessed with it. I kind of feel like it's one of those lines that would happen in a game of thrones, and if someone says it to you, sh** is about to go down. If they're like, let me steep that for you, and then you get a dagger in your neck. Well, first of all, you don't steep tea by dunking the bag. You steep tea by covering the cup. That's how you steep.
我对这句话着迷了。我总觉得这是那种会出现在《权力的游戏》里的台词，如果有人对你这么说，就要出大事了。如果他们说“让我来帮你泡一下”，然后你的脖子上就会挨上一把匕首。好吧，首先，你泡茶不是靠猛浸茶包的。你泡茶是靠盖住杯子的。那才是泡茶。
So, I was annoyed by the incorrect steeping, but I did try to zoom in on that cup, and I couldn't make it out, and I was so frustrated, and I just hoped maybe our brains were in the same place, and you were able to read it. I couldn't read it. It doesn't matter. I can let it go. Well, now I need to see it. Well, I don't know.
所以，我对这种不正确的泡茶方式感到很恼火，但我确实试图放大那个杯子，却看不清上面写的是什么，我太沮丧了，我只能希望也许我们的脑回路在同一个频道上，你能看清。我看不清。没关系。我可以放下了。好吧，现在我也想看看了。好吧，我不知道。
Anyone out there, please, will you write us? You can put it in the general mailbox. You go to officeladies.com. We have a place where you can submit questions, and there's a folder called general questions. If you've figured out what's on that coffee mug, please let Jenna know. I would appreciate it. By the way, you could also just go there and submit questions for different episodes. After the steeping business, Darrell's going to go, ahem, ahem, and Andy very earnestly
外面有任何人，求求你们，给我们写信好吗？你可以把它发到通用邮箱。你可以去officeladies.com。我们有一个可以提交问题的地方，里面有一个叫“常见问题”的文件夹。如果你看清了那个咖啡杯上写的是什么，请告诉珍娜。我会很感激的。顺便说一句，你也可以直接去那里提交关于不同剧集的问题。泡茶事件后，达雷尔“哼，哼”了两声，安迪非常认真地
says, hey, do you need a lozenge? And Darrell's like, they're a bunch of jackals. They left you in the lurch, and if they want to jump in, it means you're almost there. You did this. I'm at home. This gives Andy some confidence, and he's like, you know what, I don't need your help. It's true. Andy is going to welcome everyone back from lunch, including Mika Nos and his girlfriend,
说：“嘿，你需要一颗润喉糖吗？”达雷尔说：“他们就是一群胡狼。他们把你甩在半道上，如果他们想插手，就说明你快成功了。你做到了。”我在家里。这给了安迪一些信心，他说：“你知道吗，我不需要你的帮忙。”确实如此。安迪欢迎大家午餐归来，包括米卡诺斯和他的女朋友，
his lady friend. And for some reason, everyone has stayed after lunch, and Andy's going to let everyone go. He's just going to say goodbye, basically. So they took a whole hour for lunch, and now he's just going to say goodbye. But Michael's not going to let that happen. Michael's like, come on, you got this. You can do it. And Andy bursts back in the conference room, and he pitches this package.
他的女性朋友。不知为何，大家都留下来吃午餐，而安迪打算让大家离开。他基本上就是要说再见。所以他们花了一整个小时吃午餐，现在他居然只是要说再见。但迈克尔可不让这种事发生。迈克尔说：“拜托，你能行的。你能做到的。”然后安迪冲回会议室，推销起这个套餐。
The small business package. That's right. You need one of these. After all this great business advice I've given you, you're going to want this package to get started. No takers until Mika Nos says he wants one. And that kicks it off. Yeah.
小企业套餐。没错。你需要这个。在我给你们提供这么多棒的商业建议之后，你们会想要这个套餐来开始创业的。无人问津，直到米卡诺斯说他要一个。这就开了个好头。是的。
Andy makes three sales. Here is my question. Was this whole day worth it to sell three small business packages? No. But for Andy, yes. Andy does get a win, I guess, in a sense. Maybe his sales are so bad, these three little packages are going to be a big deal. Meanwhile, Aaron is about to win the Scrabble game.
安迪卖出了三份。我的问题是：为了卖出三份小企业套餐，折腾这一整天值得吗？不值得。但对安迪来说，值得。安迪总算赢了一次，我想，某种意义上是这样。也许他的销售业绩太差了，这三个小套餐将是一件大事。与此同时，艾琳即将赢得拼字游戏。
Oscar's trying to hint at her to play the word apoplexy. Aaron plays ape, and she loses. Yeah. I did look up the definition of apoplexy because Oscar says that he will have apoplexy if she loses. Apoplexy is the incapacity or speechlessness caused by extreme anger. He has some apoplexy. We are finally going to see Jim.
奥斯卡试图暗示她拼出“中风”这个词。艾琳拼出了“Ape（猿）”，然后她输了。是的。我查了“中风”的定义，因为奥斯卡说如果她输了，他会气到中风。中风是指由于极度愤怒而导致的失去行动能力或失语。他有点气到中风了。我们终于要看到吉姆了。
Yes. Where has Jim been? Has John been on a movie? Where was he? I think that this did spill over. That is why we took him out of the office again and gave him a very truncated storyline that basically consisted of him kicking a rock in the parking lot and sitting in his car.
是的。吉姆去哪儿了？约翰是去拍电影了吗？他去哪儿了？我觉得这确实蔓延开来了。这就是为什么我们再次让他离开办公室，并给他安排了一条非常简短的故事线，基本上就是他在停车场踢石头和坐在车里。
Well, we're going to find out because Pam's like, what's going on? The guy in the conference room is one of his childhood friends, Tom. When they were in the third grade, Jim was placed in the top reading group, which was the blue group. Actually, it was the second from the top. I like how Pam tells the story a little off. And Tom was in the green group, and Jim's mom suggested that Jim spend time hanging out with the kids in his reading group.
好吧，我们马上就要知道了，因为帕姆说：“怎么回事？”会议室里的那个人是他的童年朋友汤姆。当他们上三年级时，吉姆被分到了高级阅读小组，也就是蓝色小组。其实那是从上往下数第二个。我喜欢帕姆讲述故事时有点偏差。而汤姆在绿色小组，吉姆的妈妈建议吉姆花时间跟他的阅读小组的孩子们一起玩。
She thought that would be a good influence for him. But guess how Jim worded that to Tom? Yeah, not very delicately. My mom thinks you're too dumb to hang out with. Yeah. But also, what the heck, Jim's mom? I know. Let him have his pal that's not as good of a reader.
她觉得这对他是个好影响。但你猜吉姆是怎么对汤姆说的？是的，说得不太委婉。我妈觉得你太笨了，不能一起玩。是的。但话说回来，吉姆的妈妈怎么回事？我知道。让他有个读书没那么好的伙伴吧。
No kidding. Well, Jim is going to finally come up into the office. I guess he thinks the seminar is over, but Tom is going to walk into the kitchen while Jim is there. And wow. Wow. Talk about some snark in the kitchen. Yeah.
可不是吗。好吧，吉姆终于要来办公室了。我想他以为研讨会已经结束了，但就在吉姆在那儿的时候，汤姆要走进厨房。哇。哇。厨房里可真够冷嘲热讽的。是的。
Guess what Tom remembers? Everything. He's like, so you work here, huh? Jim's like sales. And Tom goes, must be a front for some kind of famous laboratory because you're so smart. Then he goes on at the end. He calls him like a salesman genius and goes, you know what? Great catching up.
你猜汤姆记得什么？全部。他就像是，所以你在这儿上班，哈？吉姆说销售部。汤姆接着说，这一定是什么名牌实验室的掩护，因为你太聪明了。然后他最后继续说。他称他为什么销售天才，然后说，你知道吗？很高兴叙旧。
Where's your jet pack, Zuckerberg? We had a fan question from Andrew E. in Brandon, Mississippi, and many others who said, wouldn't Jim's old elementary school friend Tom know that Jim was going to be there based on the original flyer that Andy posted with Jim's picture? And if so, do we think that it was Tom's intention the whole time to confront Jim? 100%. You think Tom sat in that conference room all day just so that he could get his moment? I mean, he got a sandwich and he finally got to like give it to Jim Halpert.
你的喷气背包呢，扎克伯格？我们有一个来自密西西比州布兰登的安德鲁·E. 以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们说，难道吉姆的小学老同学汤姆根据安迪发布的带有吉姆照片的原始传单，不会知道吉姆会在那里吗？如果是这样，我们认为汤姆从一开始就打算和吉姆对质吗？百分之百。你觉得汤姆在那个会议室坐了一整天，就为了能有他的高光时刻？我的意思是，他吃了个三明治，终于有机会把它甩给吉姆·哈尔珀特了。
Guest star alert, Tom was played by Greg Tukolescu, I hope I'm pronouncing that right, Greg, who has regularly appeared on Drunk History, College Humor Originals, and UCB Comedy Originals. Greg also lends his voice to Adam Ruins Everything, and he played Ellie Kemper's husband in Bridesmaids. Well, Greg, you were hilarious. You know, Angela, also in this scene, we see a photo of Jim Halpert in third grade. Young Jim Halpert? Mm-hmm. We had some fan questions about that.
客串明星警报，汤姆由格雷格·图科列斯库扮演，希望我没念错名字，格雷格，他经常出现在《醉史》、《大学幽默原创》和《UCB喜剧原创》中。格雷格还为《亚当毁掉一切》配音，并在《伴娘》中扮演艾莉·坎珀的丈夫。格雷格，你太搞笑了。你知道吗，安吉拉，也是在这个场景中，我们看到了吉姆·哈尔珀特三年级时的照片。小吉姆·哈尔珀特？嗯哼。我们收到了一些关于这方面的粉丝提问。
Natalie M. from New York said, is that really a photo of John in third grade? He looks like he's in at least middle school. Also, is that the name of the elementary school he went to? And Neil S. from Pennsylvania says, Jim's school photo says, hillside elementary, but there is no hillside elementary in Scranton, but there is one in Needham, Massachusetts. Randy Cordray helped me out on this one. That is a real photo of John Krasinski. I mean, I'm sure you can tell it looks like a tiny John Krasinski.
来自纽约的娜塔莉·M. 说，那真的是约翰三年级的照片吗？他看起来至少上初中了。还有，那是他去过的小学的名字吗？来自宾夕法尼亚州的尼尔·S. 说，吉姆的学校照片上写着，山坡小学，但斯克兰顿没有山坡小学，不过马萨诸塞州尼德姆有一个。兰迪·科德雷在这件事上帮了我忙。那真的是约翰·克拉辛斯基的照片。我的意思是，我相信你能看出来，那看起来就像一个小小的约翰·克拉辛斯基。
I remembered this episode when it came out and that John brought in his real picture and we're all like, oh my God, look at you. Because when we did the episode with our baby pictures, John and I did not have to bring in baby pictures. I don't know what grade he's in in this real photo, but Randy said we added and cleared the name hillside elementary, which was not his actual school. It was a fictional one that we put on the photo. By the way, that was also a real photo of Greg, who played Tom.
我记得这集刚播出的那会儿，约翰带了他的真照片来，我们都说，哦天哪，快看你。因为当我们拍带有我们婴儿照片的那集时，我和约翰并不需要带婴儿照片。我不知道他在这张真照片里上几年级，但兰迪说我们添加并清理了山坡小学的名字，这不是他真正的学校。那是我们放在照片上的虚构学校。顺便说一句，那也是扮演汤姆的格雷格的真照片。
This episode is going to end with Gabe going up to Aaron's desk. He's won, but he's going to compromise on the movie. Old tech alert, DVD boxes, look at all my DVDs. He's picked the movie Hardware. It's a real movie, by the way. Oh yeah. He says it tells the story of a killer combat robot just like Wally, and the government used it to destroy humans.
这集的结尾是盖布走到亚伦的桌子旁。他赢了，但他会在电影上妥协。旧科技警报，DVD盒子，看看我所有的DVD。他选了电影《硬件》。顺便说一句，这是一部真正的电影。哦，是的。他说它讲述了一个像瓦力一样的杀人战斗机器的故事，政府用它来消灭人类。
So it's a little something for both of them. And he's going to walk up and give Aaron a gift. It's the Shrek 2 DVD. She's so excited, so happy. Randy Cordray told me that both of those DVD covers were the real thing and they were cleared by legal. Have you seen Hardware? I have not seen that movie either.
所以这对他们俩来说都有点意思。他要走过去送给亚伦一份礼物。是《怪物史瑞克2》的DVD。她太兴奋了，太开心了。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，这两张DVD封面都是真的，并且都通过了法律部门的审核。你看过《硬件》吗？我也没看过那部电影。
I've seen Shrek 2. Same. Love it. It's so cute. The Shrek movies are great. Well you guys, that was the seminar. Thank you so much, Randy Cordray, for behind the scenes details and Dave Rogers for sharing with us about those funny bloopers.
我看过《史瑞克2》。一样。超爱。太可爱了。史瑞克电影太棒了。各位，那就是研讨会。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷提供幕后细节，以及戴夫·罗杰斯和我们分享那些有趣的失误镜头。
Thank you to everyone for writing in. Please don't forget to check out our awesome holiday merch. You can still get it in time for the holidays. Go to OfficeLadies.com. Super cute stuff. We hope you have a great week. We love you. See you next week.
谢谢所有写信的人。请不要忘记查看我们棒极了的节日周边商品。你依然可以在节日前收到。去 OfficeLadies.com。超级可爱的周边。希望你们有个棒极了的一周。我们爱你们。下周见。
Thank you for listening to OfficeLadies. OfficeLadies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of OfficeLadies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听 OfficeLadies。《OfficeLadies》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。有关《OfficeLadies》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。有关 Stitcher Premium 的免费一个月试用，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。